Hello everybody!
Hello, hello!
Let me tweet out real quick that I'm live right now.
It's our monthly check-in with our Timmy's out here on
Twitch.
I can't believe it's been a month since I last streamed on
Twitch, guys.
Are you guys still live over here?
Are my only Twitch viewers?
Are you still alive?
Don't worry.
Don't he's here to feed you.
Here you go, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm here to feed you.
Alright, I think it's here once.
Oh, Zero and Breach Buddy.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
See, don't say I don't do nothing for you guys, Twitch
goons.
Raven.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
I am very EP.
I've been EP since I woke up so I'm glad I finally have a EP
skin like a mega EP skin suit because this is how I feel
right like it's how I feel 90% um of the year oh so I did
some um I practiced a little bit off stream the last I think
like two the two to three days and um i don't know
and i don't know
all right i'm fucking i'm sorry i'm like not locked in right
now it's tomorrow um um it's very it's a very serious
tournament because everyone's screaming which is very
unlucky for me because very unlucky for me because like I
said I have this is a very to be fair it's hell year I can't
even say guys today is hell every week and the secret is
that every week is hell week so it's mostly just hell year
like because like everyone's screaming um because it's a
two-day tournament and it's so i felt that's so awkward
because i told vulgar um because the tournament is also on
sunday which i have a panel at offcat with the wildcard club
and which overlaps with the tournament and i also have like
a tech tech rehearsal and also the panel itself and and so
it's sort of over i will basically be gone for an hour so I
was like it's that cool and he's like yeah we'll get a sub
so I was like hey guys so I got to the team I was like hey
guys just so you guys know I won't and by the way that it's
that day tomorrow is just seating it doesn't really matter
that much proceeding but tomorrow is elimination so so my
team gets eliminated well because I we got a sub when I'm at
I don't come back from the pad.
I was like, guys, I'm ready to play some more rivals.
And I'd be like, guys, what happened?
So, I hope that doesn't happen.
I hope that doesn't no, Sunday, Sunday is the elimination
round.
Tomorrow is just seating.
It's just figuring out where we're seated in the tournament.
So, we play everybody once.
But Sunday is where I'd be gone for an hour of the
tournament and my sub will play like one game.
So I hope to God I hope to God that my the whoever is
subbing for me survives that one game so I could play keep
playing on Sunday like so I don't know I think it's like I
should check actually that's a good that's should check that
out i didn't read the rules because i'm not captain i'm just
i just show up um i also had i also had scrims about so
fucking dead i was so fucking dead during scrims um because
um it's my rest day but then i was like i'm gonna practice
should i practice for free or should i at least monetize it
a little bit uh yeah so i was thinking i was like because
i've been practicing Free or do I like play because I do
play rivals just for fun a lot of streamers think I'm crazy
for doing that like you play rivals for free Off stream like
yeah, I enjoy the game.
I actually enjoy the game.
So I do I do play this game off stream sometimes
But I thought I was just like yeah, I play for the love of
the game literally for the love of the game and But I also
haven't streamed on Twitch in a long time.
So I was just like, you know what?
Because I was practicing a little earlier today as well.
I've been playing on and off today.
I've been juggling between work and games just today.
And I was just like, I should, you know, I also want to make
sure I sleep.
I make sure I sleep too because the tournament is at 11 a.m.
by the way.
I uploaded the waiting room on YouTube.
So if you guys want to be like, what time's the tournament?
It's on YouTube right now.
the waiting room so i was just like well usually streaming
also makes me really tired as well right after so because i
usually get in this disassociated state uh so i was just
like well if i stream i'd be even more tired after the
stream so i can pass out instantly and then wake up for the
tournament so that's like my thought process because i have
been playing i don't know anyway so i was literally so
fucking dead for scrims today because like i haven't had
really rested since I came back from LA from the concert
like I've just been like working work like it's just been
like announcement announcement announcement announcement
announcement announcement get another announcement so many
announcements oh my god my steak is too buttery my steak is
too juicy and my lobster is too buttery and I also have two
conventions this weekend I have
and um uh and off kai too on the same week so like um i know
i took you maybe you shouldn't have said yes to the turn but
guys i'm greedy i i want to do it all i'm very i'm a very
greedy person uh and also by participating in the tournament
i get free money so
I'm min-maxing.
I get to play my favorite game and also get free...
I'm min-maxing right now.
No, I had to close my door because it is 11 p.m.
It's biblical levels of greed.
My team, my team are very...
They're all like rivals players.
I think like there's only a couple of us in this tournament
that's not like consistent rivals players It was funny
because Yeah, no, I've been playing I've been playing a lot
like literally I've been playing like every day since I
found out I was in Bougar bash So I've been practice I've
been trying to practice as much as I can I'm like I haven't
I actually haven't touched rivals since placements Which was
the last time we streamed rivals So when I found out, Boker
was like, hey, you want to do Boker Bash?
And I was like, yeah, I'm down.
As long as you got a sub for me.
And I hope that sub does well so I can keep playing on
Sunday.
When I come back from the panel, my team's still in it on
I finished my panel and then my team's eliminated.
I was like, okay, guys.
So I haven't played since I finished my placements.
And I thought it was really funny because C1 is top 500 and
I placed in C2.
I'm like, I've been playing a bit, uh, so that, and then
when Bougar was like, oh, hey, you want to do Bougar Bash?
I was like, yeah, that's, I'm cool with it.
I start playing again, so I'm trying to remember how to play
again.
Every time it's tournament season, I'm like, it's me trying
to remember how to play again.
Um, but anyway, I think it's like, um, so, uh, I've been
playing for, I think like, uh, I think I've been playing the
last three days on and off.
I've been mostly on not Doki Bird, just because it's less
pressure being on not Doki Bird because they don't know who
I am.
You know, it's less pressure because they don't know who I
am, you know?
No.
Yeah, it's like, so it's a lot more chill than playing on
Doki Bird because how would they know who it could be?
I don't never expect it.
that was like, hey, are you, hey, I know, are you Doki Bird?
And I was like, no.
Like, I typed no.
And then he was like, you know, I think even though it says
you're not Doki Bird, I feel like you are Doki Bird.
And I was like, lol, no, I'm not.
And then he was like, you know, for some reason, I don't
think I believe you.
He's like the jigs up.
You are dokeybird, aren't you?
And I didn't say anything.
I didn't get And I left him on red.
I how how would how does he know?
I mean it clearly says not dokeybird Upgrade thank you for
the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
Thank you Jakarta.
Thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
It's two in the morning for me It's so late and you're also
helping all of us when you go live here since we need to get
the twitch drop Oh, that's true.
There are twitch drops right now um watching rivals on
youtube is good too but getting free stuff for the game is
great exactly if you're watching me right now you also get
free stuff um for marvel rivals right now um what does that
want to say uh oh fuck i already lost my train of thought
i've been i'm so tired i'm exhausted but yeah uh fuck how
did i get here guys retrace my steps how did i how did i get
What was my, where did, where was, where did I get
distracted?
Guys, help me retrace my steps.
Yeah, but what was it before not, oh, oh yeah, seeing how
I've been like playing on my alt account just for less
pressure.
Oh, oh,
God, I choked him.
I choked on my saliva.
I'm a peak in peak form today.
It's alright.
I choked on my saliva.
I'm alright, guys.
Longer.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
Yeah, I went to the ROM too.
I might need some cough drops, too.
Oh, yeah.
So, my team...
Everybody's trying really hard for this tournament.
Like, everybody's screaming.
bad because they're like, can you do like, because they're
like, can you scream on this?
Like, can you scream now?
And I'm like, guys, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, guys.
unlike the other players in this tournament, Marva Rivals is
not my main content.
I just love playing the game for fun.
I just, I just love playing the game on the side when I have
time.
I was like, if you want to reach out to me, I need a day's
notice.
I was like, I need a day's, or, or like, um, like, if you
reach out to me at night, I will be free.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
I was just like, guys, I'm so sorry.
Like, I have to send my schedule and I was like, if there's
any scrims that need me, to be scheduled um luckily today
was my rest day so i i it doesn't matter because they at
first i had the screen the screen was supposed to be at
three and it canceled and they're like can we do fucking uh
like doki or can you show up at five luckily today's my rest
day so like i was because like usually i would have a stream
at five but like because today was my rest day i was like i
was like thank god i can actually scrim join the scrim today
uh but then i sent in my schedule and i was like i cannot
like if after tomorrow if i have scrims on friday or
saturday i cannot do before 5 p.m yes before 5 p.m i have
like obligations with teco and also off guy so i was like
guys i'm sorry i like guys you we have to find a gotta find
a sub like whoever the sub is that's playing for me to scrim
with you guys or it has to be at five so if we do have a
scrim the 5 p.m streams might be yeah i'm like fully booked
that's why i was like oh shit like i am i am fully booked
this week so it has my scrims have if they do want me to
scrim at five on friday or saturday we might have to do like
a two hour scrim and go straight to the video game after
like because i'm not gonna fully scrap the stream day it's
just we're gonna have a little intermission with rivals
before we go to like the corn game and and the because i
want to play the coin game and also armor core so like we're
war we're pre-gaming we're gonna be if they want me to scrim
on friday or saturday we're gonna be pre-gaming with other
games um what else did i have to say oh yeah uh but yeah my
team is uh i think like the only other content creators who
are variety streamers i think it's like me and puffer i
think that's it let me check let me check real quick i think
it's like me and because i was like i wonder if puffer has
been streaming any rivals and i checked this channel and it
was like and the first thing I saw when I looked up was pile
world and I was like my man we're both no I'm joking I I was
still I've been playing I've been playing but but I think it
was like Puffer and I are the variety streamers here but we
still play rivals we still play it it's just it's not our
main content like
what else what else oh yeah so uh so i thought it was really
funny because uh this boulder bash they did a thing where uh
they did like a auction house they were selling players i
won't talk about the uh indications of that but it was an
auction house for people so So basically, how it was set up
this time on how my team, how the teams got drafted is
basically, yeah, so basically all the captains were given
like a million bogey bucks and they were, they, bogey spun
the wheel and where, and then wherever the player landed,
the captains had to do a silent auction on the the players
so they were bidding on the people and uh coincidentally
thank god because i don't think my ego could take it i was
spun the last so because i was spun the last i don't get to
be bid on so i don't have to know how much i was worth
because because i felt so bad because i just auto-placed
because they're like oh okay since you know the last team
doesn't needs the last support so they just placed me in
there so thank god i didn't need to know how much i'm
actually worth so yeah i was just like because there were
some people that was like worth one dollar and 20 some
someone got like some people were like 300 000 boker bucks
and then the next guy got like $20.
I was just like, oh my god.
And that felt so bad because, um, um, there was someone who
got like $1.
Like, they got bid $1.
But like, obviously, like, they were like, if we could not
get them, we'll go, it'll be great.
So then, so then they got auto placed onto the, um, so they
were just I get why did I get them like I thought we tied
the bit you know and I was like that could have been me that
could have been that could have been me I was just like oh
thank God that could have been me thank God I was last like
I didn't have to know my words yeah it was a humiliation
ritual I got I was last on the wheel like fucking RNG was on
my side I escaped the auction house right
yeah I was like holy shit thank fucking god uh so yeah my
team is they're all rival streamers they're all consistent
rival players they play rivals like every day I think I saw
one of them has streamed arrivals 24 hours just yesterday uh
I made it.
I escaped the auction house.
Yeah, so, yeah, it's potato, sticky, olive, Raleigh,
Zalkdick.
I've never interacted with them before.
And that's why I was, like, super quiet during the...
That was super quiet during the scrim.
Because, like, you know, I'm like...
Whenever I'm with new people, I don't...
Like, I never interacted with them before.
I didn't really know who they were.
So I was, like, just...
Yes.
I spoke like...
I think I spoke, like...
words during I spoke like 10 words during the scrim like I
was just like I peel like peel me peel me peel me like and I
was also very fucking tired I was so tired too um because
like you know when you're I I literally ordered like um I
ordered a coffee during in uh like in the middle of the
scrim because like, I was so exhausted.
Like, you know, like when you're really tired when playing
the fast paced game that your eyes start, everything feels
too fast.
Like, like your eyes start not blurring, but like it
everything just feels like it's going faster than it should
be.
So that's how I was feeling when I was like warming up
before the scrim.
I was like, this is not good.
I was like, oh no, I cannot catch up.
Like I, I didn't, I don't know where I was shooting at but
like i think like the first i was not locked in i was so
fucking tired so i was like exhausted heading into the scrim
but i don't i think i just slept really poorly because uh
yesterday i think i just slept really poorly because
yesterday i slept at 6 a.m because i was practicing rivals
till 6 a.m solo queue um and that's why i was also like i
just didn't have like the best of sleep and i think that's
why i was like super fucking tired too um but yeah so
basically my rivals the last five what the last four days of
rivals was like today yeah so anyway I guess we can I guess
we can queue up I'm gonna get yelled at most likely I've
just been like I won't say I've been like coasting
but we might get yelled at today because because like I'm
I'm I'm a bit tired.
I'm a bit tired right now.
Do I have Venom?
Do I have the Venom twerk?
I must have, right?
I know I spent it.
Yes, I do.
Hello, Kissy.
Yeah, I'm on.
Today's just...
We're just here to...
I won't...
I hate how vibes ruined.
I can never say vibe anymore.
You're like, oh, you're vibing, so you're gonna throw.
Like, I can vibe and play.
at the same.
I can vibe and like play my best.
My best just cannot, might not be the very best of the day.
Like, I chatter.
Thank you for the Zoom chat.
Thank you.
That's nice.
Thank you for Twitch private.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm just chilling today.
Like, I'll still try my best.
I'm not gonna be throwing, but my best might not be my best
best.
Like, it might, it might not be my very best.
But it's the best of today.
Oh, hey, Madara.
Don't keep playing for the vibes.
I hate.
I can never say that word again.
It was my go-to word, too.
All right.
Time to go to solo queue hell.
It's on my alt account.
They won't know who I am anyway on this account.
Oh, yes.
Did you guys hear during the FIFA World Cup?
doing a watchdog on me during the finals you know how like
uh we saw some guys started randomly punching each other
during like the highlight scenes of like close-ups and stuff
apparently an actual fucking fight broke out uh and a riot
too apparently a riot broke out and a fight on the field
where some guy got a red card after i was like what i guess
it's just they just pay i was What's that gonna do?
I guess he just pays out like They just pay what was it 20
grand right?
How much is a red card
How much is it 20 grand?
You just minus 20 grand from the second place I guess So
they're technically just get less money Yeah Yeah they get
for those who didn't know every red card is 20 grand
Basically oh yeah I bookmarked it for those who want to see
I don't know if they I don't know if like FIFA took them
down yet let's see uh i was gonna show it to you guys
earlier but a lot of stuff was going on let me say i could
find it
oh here you go oh yeah i thought it was the just a position
of yamel praying wow like there was a fucking world war
going on behind him Which hero do you think you want to
investigate?
Like, I punched a guy.
Like, oh, sorry, it was an accident.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
Did he really...
Guys, he didn't really punch him.
His arm slipped.
Oh, I didn't even see any edit.
I wasn't even looking at the edit.
I was focusing.
sing on i was just thinking about the fucking fight
yamel's just like the same with met there's one with messy
too where he was just where he was also like he was just
going to the camera just walking to the camera and uh
it was going to the camera and then the world war three was
happening behind him too i think it's like at the same time
where yamel was fucking praying like because I remember
because I we couldn't focus on it during the World Cup watch
a lot because we were like I had to go straight to the
announcement and I was like what the fuck are they beating
each other up I like throw the games over and I was like
well anyway let's go to the announcement now I can't focus
on that like and then after that announcement I saw all the
videos about it I was like, what the fuck happened?
Like, what did it actually became a WWE fucking boxing
match?
Yeah, and then it was like Yamele and Messi just fucking
walking on the field.
Like, Yamele praying, Messi just chilling.
And then World War III behind them, between Spain and
Argentina.
All right, let's get absolutely shit on.
It's okay, they won't know it's me.
I'm on Not Doki Bird.
How would they know?
It's not Doki Bird.
This is also why I spend my time on my Outs account.
Just so they can't blame me if I am playing bad.
Because they don't know it's me playing bad.
I'm, like, basically incognito on this account.
The battle starts in 5.
Boy, they'll never know.
How would they know?
Honestly.
Oh, shit.
I was Starlord.
Nice.
That makes it easier for me, actually.
Oh, Spooner, man.
Alright.
That's fine.
Yeah, I'm doing my job.
I feel like Mantis right now, like, in the past.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, fuck me.
My bad.
That was on me.
I should have, I guess, could hit more.
It's okay.
They don't know it's me.
It's okay, guys.
They don't know I fucked up.
I feel like Mantis, though, right now.
She's, like, more... Because, like, her heels are, like,
crazy now.
That's the thing.
So I feel like she's not really used to she's not really
used to I feel like to DPS as much anymore it's more so for
heels because our heels go fucking crazy I'm just gonna save
it mostly for heels all right nice God there's too much
effects now oh it's fine we're okay Oh, nice.
You know what?
There you go.
Nice.
I don't know how I got that, but I'll take it.
I'll take credit.
I bet you I did, like, one damage, but I'll take credit.
Wait, me first?
He said me, right?
Also, I felt really bad because there was a...
I had a French player on my team during it, saying rocket
first oh right me i i all first because it sounded like he
was saying rocket first so i kept double support all thing
and then i was like i'm sorry you're so french i can't what
your accent makes it sound like you're saying rocket first
i'm so sorry you're so french bro like he got really mad he
was just like and i was like i'm sorry and he's Oh, it's
okay.
He's like, oh, okay.
He's like, I understand.
Look, he understood.
Understandable.
Oh, yeah.
Like, I legit, no, I wish I...
I wish I was streaming that, just so like...
Because, like, I swear to God, Like, when he said, like, um,
I-O first, it sounded like Rocket Vault first.
Oh, my God.
Whoops, I got distracted.
Oh, that Spider-Man has ult, too.
Oh, fuck.
That's bad.
Let me give you everything I own.
Oh, there it is.
I don't remember an exact sentence, but it legit sounded
like...
Rocket first.
Oh, shit.
That's fine.
And if it's not fine, then sometimes you're not meant to...
Oh, my God.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, my hero.
Oh, my God.
Are you sure Mr. Fantastic?
Are you sure you want to settle with Mr. Fantastic?
What the fuck is going on up here?
All right
Shit goodbye He's just getting beat up right now.
I'm sorry right on leaves All right There you go everything
I don't I feel like this is the new season like I everything
is happening It's so hard to like Fucking play this this
season I so I swear to God.
It's just, look at how many colors I'm seeing on my screen
right now.
Overall.
It's just like, all the fucking colors.
Let's go.
Let's just go.
Let's just, let's just go.
Let's just, let's just go, guys.
Let's, let's go.
Let's, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Let's go.
I'm fucking raving.
It's like, yeah, visual clutter.
That's why I'm like, my eyes get so tired easily now playing
this game.
There's just so many things going on.
Like, I'm just...
As long as you're alive.
As long as you live.
My goal is to make sure you live.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Goal is to live.
It's okay.
It's asleep.
I saved your life.
Oh my god.
What is going on?
Don't worry.
I got you.
I don't know about this guy though I knew I shouldn't stand
next to her I fucking do it I fucking do it I was like
should I stand I cannot I shouldn't be a 1TP I'm 81% alright
alright here we go
no we did everything we could There was no way I should TP.
I had 88.
I could have fucking given us if we got that TP.
Alright, here we go.
I think it doesn't help.
Maybe playing when I'm tired was not the smartest.
Oh, wow!
Wow!
It's alright.
Hello, Cloak.
If you get...
Oh my god, he's one.
He's actually one.
No.
Alright, you go shoot things.
Is stuff happening?
I can't tell.
There's 20 things on my screen.
It's stuff happening.
Oh my god, I couldn't even...
Oh, here you go.
Here.
Maybe that'll hit someone.
Oh, I hope you live.
Well, I said I hope.
Okay, goodbye
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're alive though the people that matter are alive All
right, we're gonna need our cloak to build all but like it's
really hard because I really do don't think I don't think he
can build all in time
Please there's so many people
I tried.
I really did.
Oh, my God.
No, I cannot heal that.
I cannot heal that.
I'm sorry.
Guys, it's okay.
I'm on not Doki Bird.
When you're right when I'm playing this game, it's hard.
I believe you're not.
I think you're fine.
as long as you're not in the higher evil the high evil you
guys might be the worst person hey it's star lord not me
it's it's okay it's okay he's talking about star lord okay
you aren't even using the right demon that's true he needs
to be using the other one scarlet thank you for the uh we
did we won our scrims um i was like not i was half awake too
for it so i just call that as a win just waiting till both
stuff gets over on then they're just using their dps also in
the fight um but scarlet they give the five dollars donation
they can thank you kick ass and take names keep on laughing
saying sean long live don't get it thank you can't wait to
see you as a tech account and off guy guys can't wait to
lock my uh event staff's credit card again an off guy
all right here we go i had to like i actually uh oh shit
it's my dog shit off tank and my dog shit start to Hey, not
me!
Not me!
This is not...
Hey, not me though!
Surprisingly not blaming the supports!
Thank God, look at me, you missed all these shots.
It's alright.
Whoa.
Not... Oh, okay, maybe me.
I don't know, I went to the top right and I was like, ooh,
top right is dangerous.
Maybe I shouldn't.
Look, they didn't mention the mantis.
I'm not the problem, you know?
Yeah, when I don't get called out.
Don't you love it?
What the fuck?
What is this?
Who is you, me?
Yo, I think this might be a team diff right there.
I don't know.
I have a feeling this might be a team diff.
Whoa.
As long as my low-key is gonna be fine, I did 360 because I
won't be sure that she's okay.
I hear the iron fist right now.
You see?
Yeah, he's gonna be fine.
Gonna be fine.
You know, fuck it.
yo all right let's leave i don't know oh that hits me let's
all right where was that that hits me i had
it's all right i'm surprised that fucking hit me i know okay
maybe our the guy that talks is actually doing though See,
he talks shit, but he's showing, you know, he, he's showing
that he can talk shit.
He can dish it, you know?
Okay, he does.
Oh, nice.
Not nice anymore.
Well, I hope our...
Loki, I'm right here.
I'm right here.
If you ever need me, if you need me.
Oh, he blocked it.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Just in case.
I would like to be in a...
my safe spot.
There we go.
Just in case.
Astro Man.
Veltor, they give it to your one.
Thanks, it's up.
Thank you.
Alright.
Give me high, girl.
Oh my gosh.
Like, good for our Elsa, you know.
We're still trying.
Even after.
You know.
Even though she hates our team.
You know, she's still, at least she's still trying.
At least she's still trying to kill things instead of going
on Scarlet Witch or something.
Like, that's better.
That's better than what it could be.
Like, he didn't go straight to, like, blood.
It's the little things.
It's the little things, guys.
He didn't go straight to blood.
Or Scarlet, you know, or Squirrel Girl.
He's just, he's still playing the game.
even though he hates us.
He has a lot.
He fucking has a lot.
I should start shooting.
There you go.
Let's go!
I called it!
I knew he was gonna do that too.
I had a feeling.
That's why I went high ground.
Well, I'm dead.
Oh, he couldn't cop- oh, he doesn't have coffee.
Do I still like playing Luna?
Luna's alright.
I don't play as much anymore because like meta is like
Mantis and Mantis.
Alright.
Oh hey, nice.
I'll go run over.
Mantis is fun too.
There's more survivability on Mantis because she has the
self-heal.
It's like Mantis.
Also, I don't have to aim as much.
Mantis playstyle right now is just like it's like old old
luna playstyle i don't know if that makes sense but that's
her that's like her new playstyle which is like just exist
and heal oh not again i feel like
yeah as long as i'm alive i just have to be like lucio just
survive
Because she does so much healing.
I feel like she does more healing than Luna now.
Yeah.
Yeah, modern Luna is more stunned, but I think Mantis is
more fun.
Oh my god, he blocked it again.
I feel like I don't play with enough.
I don't play against enough Iron Fist.
Alright.
Am I?
Where's my...
Which one's my team?
you know what let's go i'm gonna try and see if i can all
right well i really wanted to kill these guys but that's
fine i don't know if i should maybe i shouldn't have altered
that that might have been a little bit too much it's okay
they won't know it's me they won't know though
They won't know it's me, guys.
It's okay.
Oh, I didn't hit him.
Oh, holy shit.
Oh, nice.
It went better though if it was against her.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that was low key, exactly.
I ulted first, technically.
Yeah, it was the one that ulted first, so I don't know why
our low-key copy there.
Like, it was already winnable.
Jesus Christ.
I feel like the game is a lot faster paced now.
Oh, shit, sorry.
You know, if you tell me you need help, you sure, I need
healing.
Like, that guy, but, like, um...
that guy but it working like just like that guy but like
what if it works you know oh shit look you didn't say I need
healing how was I supposed to know he needed healing every
time guys I swear to get out okay I got really scared for
Alright, Elsa.
I don't want him to yell at me because he seems really
angry.
Really?
That didn't... Oh!
Oh!
Oh, I don't...
It's okay.
Kill the rocket!
Wait, is the rocket dead?
Alright, nice.
Yeah.
As long as our Elsa lives.
three Oh I'm just like playing hope our Elsa As long as I
pocket my Elsa he won't be mad at me You know That's the
That's the key I just gotta make sure our Elsa's happy Never
over till it's over Sorry I'm just stalling I'm just here to
get XP I guess if we lose
I love this new outfit by the way when spied I'm always
tired I'm like I'm eepy every time I stream this is how I
feel deep down yeah that also has everyone I mean please
avoid my rock not me not me surprisingly I have a hundred
percent win rate on rocket on my main account I don't know
how that happened.
Why did you crash the Milano here?
Of all places.
Not me!
He says he's you.
Well, who are you gonna believe?
That's right.
This is a solo cute life.
No one wants to play with me.
It's okay.
I don't need nobody.
It's because they don't know it's me.
That's why no one wants to play with me on this account.
Guys.
I'm not coping.
Who needs friends exactly why should I share guys it's cuz I
don't want share my games
It's I'm so tired of carrying people You're right.
I'm a strong independent woman I need to keep my leaves I
don't want to waste it I'm gonna keep it on here Okay, I'm
gonna damage oh my god Okay.
All right.
I was like, I'm gonna...
All right, guys.
I am a little worried for us because I really don't want to
waste my leaves.
But like, you guys are all scaring me.
Oh my god, where are you?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Five.
Oh my god.
I hope.
Oh god.
If you need to copy me, I'm right here.
I'm right here.
If you need to copy me.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I need the damage boost.
You please kill anybody.
Alright.
We're right here.
guys we're okay all right okay we did it we did it all the
colors every single can you name all the colors of the
rainbow I just I just saw it I just saw it on my screen I
think I saw the entire rainbow just now
I just saw, yeah.
You're truly my...
Hey, you're getting a draw.
You know, I'll take this.
Oh, shit.
Have I been lagging this entire?
Wait, no.
I can't tell.
Have I been lagging?
I don't know if I'm lagging or not.
Have I been lagging or no?
Like me.
I'm fine.
I'm fine now.
Yeah, I think it's just so many colors.
Oh, I just...
No, I think it's just...
The game just overloaded.
Any advice for Captain Mains?
This is not the right place.
I play.
I have legitimately only one, two days of tank experience.
And Captain was not.
Captain America was not one of them.
It's like facing the rainbow.
I don't know, Damage Rock.
Aren't you a support player?
I don't know duo support it's a little it's a little risky
there
don't worry don't worry I got the damage boost on you
Jesus Christ oh
no raid boss down what are we gonna do Our best player just
died!
Oh, hey, I got a kill.
Nice.
I mean, I'll take this.
Oh, I can't even...
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry to...
No, if I do, I wouldn't have used...
If I do, I would have...
This is real firepower!
Oh, please.
No!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Get on, get on!
Oh my god!
Fast!
How did I die so fast?
Three, two, four.
It's okay, we gotta draw.
I said, you know, a draw is actually...
I got bursted so hard there.
Avoid my rocket and Elsa.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
god oh was that lucky zeal i can never tell he has so many
different accounts and different names
yeah a draw is technically a win nobody lost and you know i
technically i won because nobody flamed me and i call that a
win in my heart yeah yeah
Technically, because nobody flamed me, I won.
That's a win right there.
Yeah, that's a support win.
It's a W.
Look, we both lost points.
You know what?
It's fine.
Because you know who's even more mad or else?
Oh, I should avoid.
Actually, I don't know.
I feel like my team was like, wait a minute.
Wait, minus 20, wait, wait, did they, they didn't cap?
Did we both lose minus 20?
They got, they got one bar.
Okay, never mind.
It's okay, I didn't get, I didn't even, I didn't even see,
notice they got a tick.
I feel like everybody did all right.
Maybe we didn't have a low key, but like, it's fine.
I didn't even realize they got an entire bar.
that game well i was i don't even know what i was doing
thank you surprisingly you guys didn't notice i play better
off stream i play i get more frames and also i'm less
confused i don't have to multitask i don't i do no ball
that's why i wrote my application um joy boy thank you I
don't need frames.
I can like predict with my mind.
I basically can see like where they're gonna go through like
minery.
I'm like in their head.
You play any DPS?
I play Apex.
That's DPS.
That's technically DPS.
Who needs... Exactly.
Who needs frames?
When I can like literally... Like who needs frames?
You just put your crosshair on their head.
I think also like I I don't care as much anymore just
because like I just play to play so like I don't really care
about losing Elo or gaining I mean I get happy when I gain
Elo but like losing Elo doesn't affect me as much anymore
because like I literally I play off stream like I just I
play off stream get like casually no I'm chilling I'm not
vibing I'm chilling like that's why i say like i technically
i didn't lose because no one flamed me that's like that's
the win in my book as long as nobody flames me i'm winning
yeah not being blamed it's surprising very hard it's
surprise like in marble rivals like getting flamed is like a
50 50.
it just depends on which target they shoot at 30 seconds
before you attack
even when you're winning you can still get flamed it's the
little victories in life maybe i should play luna i have to
play luna anyway mantis is just too good though if no one
else is playing mantis there's i feel like we're just
throwing mantis is too good i mean i could be throwing by
not playing mantis is iron man good i don't know all right
widow you would me hey she's almost dead why are you back
out pussy i'm diving oh back out back out back out i saw
iron fist oh it's the guy that
Oh shit, it's our dive.
Never mind.
I might have to play...
Oh, I hate playing White Fox.
I don't have enough experience on it.
I'm actually just going by instinct if I play here.
I'm gonna save my leaves for dive.
Alright, in this...
I'm saving all my...
all my leaves on you!
Wait, you're not her.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Don't walk backwards, please.
Don't walk all the way.
Alright.
I'm just following.
Hey, he said don't walk backwards, guys.
I'm just following the crowd.
If I don't walk backwards, I'll die.
I'm trying.
You guys know what?
You guys, no swing.
Let's go!
No!
Let's disappear!
I got a little...
Oh my god!
Alright.
Let's...
I might have...
I don't know even if I gave her leaves.
I think I actually have to go White Fox.
I...
I think that was the same iron fist you like just burst last
it was on my team last game you did absolutely no
Oh, that's the worst, you know
When you
I can't play the game
Look, I am...
Oh my god, all right.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Let's...
I don't think we can...
I'm trying.
Oh my god.
I don't even know what she's saying anymore.
She's like mumble wrapping in my ear.
I'm getting ASMR right now.
I know there's a Venom on you guys.
I promise you I will feel like you.
I feel like hearing like mumble wrap.
I can't even hear what she's saying.
I hope she's not blaming me.
There we go.
I don't think it was a walk forward thing.
It's a maybe a white fox thing.
I think it's a white fox.
He's saying buy a token, right?
He's not aware yet.
He's going to overtime.
All right.
I don't know.
Oh, let's go.
Oh, that's five.
That was good.
All right.
Two, one.
Put the Wi-Fi.
It's out of position.
Start.
This is bad.
I don't know.
Like, I can't find anything.
What?
Why do we keep walking backwards?
Guys, we just have to support.
Guys, I walk forward.
I walk forward.
I walked forward walk forward
I walked forward I walked forward I was there I was getting
absolutely fucked up in there I I walked I walked forward I
I only walked back because my alt was done I think he's been
losing a little too much guys see this is why i'm not on my
main see this is this is why i'm not on my main let her die
you need to keep the people let her die just let her die why
we're not walking forward i can't i'm i'm at a perfect
position oh another fighter has joined Join the ring Ricky
Robbins join the VC
New challenger has arrived
Watch I'm literally walking forward with you my team is
still behind me Please watch the ring Guys just I I didn't
walk forward That's my bad.
That's my bad.
No, shit.
My bad, I didn't walk forward.
Guys, can we walk forward more?
I don't, why are we so...
Guys, why are we not walking forward, guys?
Just walk forward.
He sounds so scary.
I don't think I should have used the ship there, but I don't
want him to yell at me more.
Guys, guys, guys, guys, we're walking backwards, guys.
Guys, guys, guys, we're losing because we're not walking
forward.
Guys.
Hey, guys, why are we still walking backwards?
Oh, your microphone is off so very...
What did I do?
I'm trying to walk forward!
I swear to God, I was walking forward.
I don't know why he regrouped me up.
Please watch the replay.
I'm only not one...
Holy not!
You're not...
You're talking to the wrong person.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Every time I walked forward, I felt like I was frontlining.
I...
I think it's okay.
not me but yeah i'm just like guys yeah guys i'm forward but
i feel like i feel i feel like i shouldn't be the only one
forward right yeah i was like am i frontlining is this is
this what i'm supposed to do who the fuck has support to be
the v shield i know i was just like guys like am i fuck me
Yeah Yeah, I walked for where was my Bucky?
Why was he not walking forward right?
I guess the other team walked for guys, please ignore this I
had a good time though.
Okay, but like guys ignore this I don't know I don't I guess
our widow, but I feel like uh Okay, but my main account is a
lot prettier though the main account It's the yes, it's the
streaming debuff guys This is I'm just it's the streaming
debuff I'm getting all the losses out of the way right now
So during the tournament it'll be better I don't even know
who to avoid I guess He's already avoided me so I don't have
to care Yeah He's already avoided me I guess I'll avoid If
they're bad or not.
I can't tell.
Yeah.
The Iron Man?
Was he bad?
I can't tell.
I legitimately didn't even know who...
I guess Hippo?
I mean, Hippo plays tank and they're rare these days.
They're a rare breed.
It's okay.
Maybe like the other players will avoid...
You know, the other players will avoid me.
So...
Uh...
tanks are going extinct who wants to play guys did you not
see what was going on on my screen guys like the like
imagine playing tank and that's your that we saw what's
going on my screen and i'm on the back line imagine you're a
tank and you see that but like closer
yeah like all of those colors but you're like literally the
front line of all those colors pack line yeah oh sorry
you're right technically i was front line i was frontlining
when he kept saying go forward
it's all right i don't really care what happens on this
account anyway
uh and aniwawa thank you for the 50 uh for the raid thank
you thank you for party a 50 raid i don't know i got i don't
know why i thought it was a gifted sub for some reason
please excuse me i'm tired right now i want to get more the
why i'm playing as i want to get like more eepy so i can um
then go to bed easier because i like i don't have a regular
sleeping schedule but thank you for great oh yeah that's not
a great stream just playing some um just playing some rivals
um and enjoying a good time i have a tournament tomorrow so
i'm just trying to remember how to play the video game no i
have been practicing though i have been practicing and i
usually i focus up when i'm in tournament mode so like right
now because i'm just i'm playing rank so like i am focused
but is like less focused than when i'm playing in a
tournament yeah it's booger bash it's booger bash
oh somebody has shitty internet i think the thing i worry
about the most is our captain dcing apparently our captain
has internet issues so like i hope he doesn't dc that'll be
awkward
because he's playing from he's the only one playing from
australia the other players are playing from enu so he had
he literally has the australian debuff because he's the only
one from australia and like everybody i think he's the only
one playing from asia like technically like you know west
coast uh yeah technically like west coast type servers so
like everyone else is like european so like you know east
coast will favor them the most so he literally has the
australian debuff yeah but apparently we're doing balance
latency so we're over everybody else like balance latency oh
the europeans are not going to be happy about this right
yeah it doesn't matter for like the people in na because
we're playing on na servers but the europeans are not going
to be happy because i'm west coast so balance lacing doesn't
matter to me
oh yeah by the way remember i was just announced this also
on like a regular stream not the twitch stream but we
unfortunately well fortunately for me but my manager was
like unfortunately because this was not what he wanted uh oh
gambit i feel like gambit mantis is so strong though God
damn it, I need to play...
Matt, this is just too strong.
But, so, we ended up selling more than 69 limited edition
bundles because it went by too fast that, like, I think, 40
slipped in.
Yeah, you know, like, it's apparently sold out in 20
seconds, but because it was, it sold out so fast, 40 bundles
slipped in.
So I said and he was like no I think more I don't remember I
don't remember the exact number
No, when it comes to the hunt we bloodstones have always
been how many hours you need for the skin Gil Yeah, you just
all yeah, what do I do with this boy?
What do I number them?
Well now I have to sell it 420 to make you to make it even.
To keep the whimsy.
69a, like we do the whole alphabet.
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
Hello?
How did everybody...
Oh, Jesus.
You died for...
You died for the thing.
What happened?
I think they're very, very...
dead.
How do you even damage boost him?
That's the thing.
What the fuck happened?
I was like that they were gone.
This team knows ball.
They really do.
I don't give another damage boost just in case.
Give me that.
The hole is the goal.
Oh, whoa.
I heard the servers are super lagging now.
All right, holy fuck what's going on?
You know what?
There we go.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I'm giving you my leaves.
I'm giving you my leaves!
Oh my god, don't worry.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Sorry, buddy
Am I all right?
I have all of but like I I'm not using the alt for that bro.
I Sorry bro.
That's not worth it Guys guys guys guys guys we're gonna do
something really crazy guys.
We're gonna do this see we're just gonna run forward guys
what how did no it's okay no i would does he know i'm here
what the me for what okay
Holy shit!
Yes, fuck you in particular.
Yeah, I'm like one game away from C1 on my main.
Also, I haven't been playing on my main.
New perspective.
Hey, I just spawned in.
You can't blame me.
I got all up before Gambit, so you can't blame me.
Nothing is ever my fault.
Oh my god, I think our panther might need a swap, though.
And our thing.
Oh my god, there's a lot of swaps that need to happen.
Like, nobody is diving, guys.
Nobody is diving.
Okay, alright, I'll swap off.
But, okay, even me?
Even me?
But Mantis, he was so strong.
You know, if you had all with that, though, it would have
been even cooler.
Nice.
I'm trying to give you a leave right now.
Okay, R.
Just in case, just in case.
I I'm very much very much afraid.
I'm very oh my god.
Oh my god, please Please come to me!
That's there!
Oh, please Oh, I don't have I don't have enough heals
Oh, I would love to oh my
I'm swapping.
I didn't think we would lose that fight.
Let me swap.
Let me swap now.
I know.
I'm so...
You know, I can practice.
I'm doing it.
You're just taking too much damage.
We don't need you.
I can cancel!
holy shit okay i'll take that we don't need you thing oh we
don't need you you're not here that what the fuck please
somebody kill this guy oh shit not me again okay okay It's
true.
Please come down.
Oh my.
I won't say he's right because of the fact that we got point
just because I swapped.
It's not because I swapped that we won the point, guys.
That's the reason.
Madness was not the issue.
Jesus Christ.
I need a clap.
Hey, I hope we...
I hope we gamut up.
Alright.
Precision.
What?
Alright.
Okay, I healed.
I healed.
If anything, our Gambit wasn't looking.
Gambit, you first, Gambit.
You first, unless you said me first, but it's you first.
There we go.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
All right, let's go.
Okay, I don't know what's going on.
All right, we did it.
We did it.
Weird.
It's not because I swapped that we did.
It's not me.
It's not because we swapped, guys.
It's...
It's not because we swapped.
It's because it's true.
It's because I didn't press W.
No, not at all.
It's not.
In fact, me swapping is just enabling bad behavior from my
thing.
It just encourages bad gameplay and bad habits.
to learn because of my swap.
He's not going to level up as a player.
So in fact, me swapping is a bad thing.
Yeah, encourages him to dive more and do more bad plays.
We have to make him.
Yeah, suffering builds character.
Yeah, don't Cater team.
Make them cater to me.
You're right.
Just make them tell him to walk forward.
They're not learning the right lesson.
Him encourages him to int more.
And that's not a good thing, guys.
I think I actually have to play up from them here.
Where the fuck is our mag?
Our guy's gonna fucking die without the mag life support.
Like, he will kill himself in rivals.
Like I don't believe in him in saying a lot Yeah, he is
literally the mags like the mag is oh my god
Let's hope our fuck okay.
I I knew the moment I I knew that was gonna happen too No,
he absolutely needs that snowflake.
Oh my god, he's actually coming back.
Like me giving other players the snowflake scares me.
That's not a mess.
Oh, I waste that.
I should not waste that, honestly.
Okay.
Let's...
Oh, okay.
Oh, no.
I thought our gambit was gonna- I thought my gambit would
get it!
I thought my cabin would get on faster!
That was my bad.
I didn't think he was 97 for so fucking long.
He was 97.
I was literally waiting 20 years for him to get on.
And now I was like, fuck this.
I couldn't wait anymore.
Oh, that's on me.
I should have just fucking played chicken.
I should just lay him out no matter what.
I was just like, bro, is he...
Does he have all?
Does he fucking have all?
No, no.
He's blaming me now.
No!
No, I threw that only because that...
Why?
Okay.
Oh, no.
I'm fucking dead.
Unless he has bubble.
I'm still dead.
He bubbled me so early.
Oh my god.
Someone needs a snowball in the face.
Oh no.
Now I am getting flame.
No!
The one thing I didn't want.
Now I truly lost.
I truly lost now just killed me welcome all right thank you
for the raid thank you thank you
usually you let the gambit out first so i was like you know
i was i thought our gambit would get up first i even was
like all right i'm not gonna i'm not gonna I'm gonna then
build up All right, there we go there we go we got out
We did it Oh
my god, I'm gonna let him build up I don't want to clap I
don't want to clap Wait, wait, are things swapped?
Wait, it's winnable Guys!
Are things swapped?
I didn't even notice!
Holy shit.
Wait, there's a sniper behind us.
Is he okay?
Oh, he is not okay.
Okay.
They need the ball!
No, please just block me.
all right i there's nothing this there's no way i could live
that there's no
they double they double alted we're both shit
it's okay they also double alted
oh shit
I'll do reload.
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
At least their supports are getting yelled at right now,
too, guys.
I take the little victories in life.
Like, their support is also...
Jesus Christ.
How do you feed even on Emma?
It's actually impressive.
Holy shit.
Only 60 second flight.
We strong together.
I am spied a sniper and cut them.
Alright.
Okay.
That's fine.
I'm trying to let my gambit heal more.
Alright, I have to clap this.
I have to clap this.
Oh my god!
There we go.
Gambit never falls.
Where's my bag?
Three, two, one!
Oh,
please, I'm alive.
We're still alive.
Look, I did the best I could.
All right.
There's a res.
Have a res.
Oh my god, where the fuck was that?
Hello earlier.
Yeah.
Three, two, three.
Yeah, not, they're blaming the M and the M too.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Not.
Yippee.
It's everybody's problems.
I shine in darkness.
Everyone but me.
Yeah.
Pew, pew, pew, pew.
I'm not the only problem.
We all suck.
Yippee.
Yo, Luna, can we go Invis?
So we're getting all as quick as we're getting all as quick
as they do.
And we're losing the support all tights.
Whoa.
I get all faster than our gambit.
I legit get all.
faster than our fucking gambit if anything I should be
playing gambit guys in before the gambits complaining
they're duode with the black panther what's crazy I got it
first every time what the fuck oh my god that There should I
give them until the count of four to walk away?
There's no way I saw me getting all I
Would like if you guys want me to play in this you guys have
to play together Like
Like you're not playing together
Holy shit!
Oh, I'm not getting as fast as the other support.
Maybe because you're not grouped up.
Like what the fuck?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
They're not, why are both my tanks split up?
Both my tanks decide to go left and right.
That's crazy.
And they're like, yo, you get, I'm actually, I'm fucking,
that's it.
I saw that, and I was just like, you know how infants build
up fast?
If both tanks decide to play in the same core angle, like,
how am I supposed to build up?
Oh, look at that, I got up.
I'm gonna hold it as soon as I get it and I'll move the
group.
Come on!
There we go.
What the... how?
Okay.
Alright.
I gave my...
Widowsy.
I was like, wow, the moment my tank started grouping up.
I should have played Loki.
I just didn't want to play Loki because Loki is so, like,
meta-play now.
Because her ult charge is so slow in general.
Jesus Christ.
I'm...
Oh, yeah.
The current score is 3.
Oh, they see none.
They've...
Time to switch things up.
They see none.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
I'm not the type who fades the quiet range of background.
They actually see none.
What do you mean?
He was on Black Panther!
Why?
That's crazy.
This guy's...
It was like, I'm not getting healed.
I'm on Black Panther.
And I'm in their spawn.
Where's my heals?
Where's my fucking heals?
I don't want to play low key because his ult charge is so
slow and I can't be bothered.
I don't even have to play low key too for the tournament.
So there's no point.
Kill me in their spawn, please.
Yeah, I can't give him a snowflake.
too.
Bro, Mac, are you playing?
I think my team just hates each other, guys.
The C1 being saved.
Bro, this guy has a tracker, too.
He actually is using a tracker to shit talk.
That's so sad.
But this entire team is just He's literally pulling our
trackers and everything too Because my profile is extra
hidden There's trackers out there right now that Where it
bypasses everything essentially Like it doesn't matter It
doesn't matter Like what is our It doesn't matter Because
the coding for rivals allows you to
so they're literally they're literally using the tracker
just to shit talk that's
insane that's so funny
I like how he's just damage boosting now oh I should kept my
push whatever oh my god I almost have it though please
please please This is just keep me up, please.
Oh my god, I literally just got it.
I literally...
I'm trying to keep you up, bro.
Oh my god, you actually got pushed everywhere.
Bro, give me alt, bro.
3, 2, 4.
Alt, what?
Alt!
It doesn't matter where that man is going.
Yeah, you can't expect to win them all.
Where is the mag?
Oh my god, yeah.
Holy shit.
I ulted with the mantis.
With the mag in there.
That guy's on and this guy's on and all.
I want to know who that guy is.
Wait, no.
This guy is trying to be a pro player.
I don't think...
If you're in this elo, bro, I don't think you're going to
cut it and make it here.
Man, is everyone...
I think I'm, like, the happiest player in Rivals today.
I think...
I think I think I'm the happiest player in Rivals.
I think, yeah, yeah, perhaps.
The bar is surprisingly not that high.
I'm just happy to be here.
I mean
The bar is surprisingly the bar is like people who don't
care That's me Happiest rivalist player in the world right
now I'm exactly where I want to be I'm the most whimsical
player For peak C1 Bro any Bro He's saying that But he's
here and he's using trackers to shit talk like that's crazy
it's actually crazy if you have to use street trackers to
get an advantage in Marvel rivals in this Elo that's you've
already lost you've already lost a mental game yeah like bro
you're here with me you're here with me literally here with
me bro the double is doing pull-ups on the bar right now
c1 using a paid tracker is trying to be pro bro pick a
struggle true no i think this was like a c3 average game too
that's the most sad part it was like a it was a c3 average
because this account is c3 my main is like one game off of
and my main is one game off of c1 which is currently top 500
uh and the fact that this is why you get alt accounts at
this time because it's just elot terrorism hours and i'm one
of them but i'm i'm not like you know i'm not like that much
of an elot terrorist but i'm still up there uh when you
catch me off stream you play your team players want to catch
me off stream yeah yeah if don't keep it is streaming her
rank games that's when you know it's bad you you would want
me on your team if I'm off stream because that's when I'm
actually locked in that's the reason why because it's an alt
account I don't care too much yeah it's a bad day for them
if I'm streaming my ranked games all right let me see uh i
feel like i've already got avoided so i don't need to avoid
anyone oh no i have i'm gonna avoid that one guy this guy
like everybody would avoid each other so it doesn't matter
to me in general but like for sure i have to avoid that one
guy over there yeah i'm not struggling i'm just i'm just
here
Yeah, no, I have to avoid the Gambit.
I'm confused, too.
I'm confused.
And then he told me to swap off support.
Please don't mind the last streak, guys.
I was losing.
I was just...
I was also...
It was not all on stream.
I also lost some off stream.
And he was the one that said, don't ban Gambit, too.
He was the one that said, don't ban Gambit.
You're right.
Losing Builds.
character.
Does the gammon not get ult fast?
No, because you heal too fast.
I got my ult first, but he was like stuck.
I stopped healing for five.
I stopped healing for 10 seconds.
That's the thing.
I stopped healing for five, like five to 10 seconds, and he
was stuck on like, it was so slow for him to get 95 to 100.
That's why I was just like, what the fuck are you healing?
I was just like, it was just like, like bro just if you
throw if he threw one card out you would have got it so i
was so confused i literally i was like i'm giving you 10
seconds bro if you don't get it i'm alting he didn't get it
and then we both at least i brought him down with me
you know because we both support alted we he also got blamed
and that's a win for me
you know what the good thing though the good thing about
rivals Overwatch, if I do get, I mean, if I'm getting
avoided today, is that, if you guys didn't know in
Overwatch, if you get avoided, if you get avoided too much
in Overwatch, you actually get a suspension.
You get suspended because you get avoided too much so you're
considered, like, so you're considering Elo Terrorist, and
Overwatch doesn't like that.
Blizzard doesn't like that.
And I don't know if they stopped doing that, but in the
past, if you avoid it too much, you literally get suspended,
or I don't know how long.
Because I remembered people would tweet about it.
Like, all the one tricks would get suspended.
Because Blizzard considers that as throwing.
Just go, like, oh, why are you getting avoided so much?
But in Rivals, if you avoid it too much, you just have a
longer queue.
That's really it.
Where you get suspended?
Someone behind got suspended for just being bad.
But it also depends on, like, what Elo you're in, too.
But, like, in Rivals, it's just...
It doesn't really matter.
You know, it's crazy.
Every game, someone's been really, really mad.
But also every game I've lost today.
We gotta see when the losses stop.
You know, I'm committed now.
I want to know when it stops.
I would love to play with someone to also lose with me.
Because what makes me feel better about losing is that I'm
also dragging someone down into the pits of hell.
And they aren't more mad than me.
Yeah.
That's the best stuff.
Misery loves company, you know?
As long as they're also losing, it makes me happier.
Well, I don't want, like, my team to be sad.
I can't be sad because I'm on Elit's account.
Guys, I cannot make my team also be fucking miserable
because they'll be miserable.
I'm not.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
They're miserable, but I'm not.
So, like, we don't want to start off miserable for them.
But, like, if any of my friends...
Yeah, I want to drag my friends down.
let's see yeah if i'm drowning and someone tries to save me
i'll make sure we both go down
i think i'm practicing i think guys i'm getting the losses
out of the way now so during the tournament it's all wins
honestly if if my team wants me to win they should tell me
to not stream but i don't think the tournament organizers
are gonna be happy about that i think the tournament
organizers would want me to stream but my team really wants
me to win wants us to win it will actually be beneficial if
I don't stream not streaming doki wins all right guys I'm
walking forward oh I just chucked that my bad I just wanted
to have fun hey guys i am
all right cool how do i go okay i'm going from here
oh let's hope they're getting healed right now
nice oh what that doesn't hit okay that's bullshit that
should have hit not gonna lie what do you mean that doesn't
bro Rocky you gotta Rocky I'm trying to help you bro
oh my god someone get that squid boy oh my god Alright, here
we go.
Oh no, my stream's not working guys.
Oh no, what do I do?
Come on.
I'm clapping, I'm clapping, I'm telling to myself because I
don't talk to people in games.
Thanks so much.
Is that...
Oh shit.
Is my team...
okay oh he's going back in round two all right I'm clapping
I'm clapping I'm clapping I'm doing my part let's go let's
go we let it run come on keep getting all right I leave you
guys now yo see equivalent exchange right here.
All right.
Hello.
Thanks so much.
I think that was a good exchange.
Not going to lie.
Oh, shit.
That was not what I wanted to do.
What?
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm on here.
I don't know what's going on anymore.
Like, nice.
Can we guys?
I mean, okay.
Hey, is everyone, there's a raccoon right here.
Guys!
I should guys Come on guys Is everything
okay over there?
Oh my god, new reload
I like how nobody's shot at the raccoon No one on I know I
was like guys, please Okay Okay, that might be a little
overkill, but that's fine.
I hope people are yelling at each other on the enemy team.
That's all I want.
I hope the enemy team is miserable right now.
I hope they're all yelling each other, and they're trying to
find who to blame, and then they're going to have a terrible
day.
Because that brings me joy.
That's evil.
I hope they're trying to figure out who to blame right now.
Alright, you first?
Yeah, I'm down with that.
Alright, I gotta need...
Oh, the rocket and the widow are duo.
The rocket and the widow are duo 100%.
How do I know that?
Literally, target acquired.
Amp.
You can't...
You can't coordinate that.
I hope they double support us.
They're 100% duo.
Who the fuck combos?
Is that?
Oh, he definitely has a...
Who is he arming?
Alright, four, three, two, one of us will die and it's not
me!
Thank you, God.
There we go.
Yay!
Yippee!
Venno, thank you for the gift that's up!
Thank you, thank you!
I just convinced my friends that I am a good person, won't
you?
do you mean oh my team's having fun i only have to sacrifice
the rocket i just want us to have the same kda do you know i
just want us to i want him to i want him to have more deaths
than me
funny how no vc goes when it's because we're winning right
now at the moment the moment they we start losing
everybody's gonna start start slurring and it's fine well
it's not fine uh avoid v7c avoid fucking spooky spooker for
free wins too bro all bad all of them
see every game you're talking about v7 every game nobody's
safe What's up?
I just never expected this whole- Every game, guys.
It's just life.
Well, you know I've got your back.
Whether it's at home or out on tour.
Hippy.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Are you gonna get avoided too?
Most likely, I won't be surprised.
They're like, avoid Doki Bird.
Not- sorry, not Doki Bird.
Maybe I should have a more incognito.
More...
Oh, sorry.
Maybe I should have a username that's a bit less suspicious.
Alright, nice.
I'm clapping.
I would hope they know that I'm clapping right now for the
team.
The thing is, their rocket has literally the wrong team up
right now.
Because it's supposed to be the group team up.
up all right i'm clapping i'm clapping i'm doing my job
that's right oh trio they'll never know oh i hope that guy
doesn't die oh he's fine he has health pack there you go oh
they're running stop aiding so i can kill you God.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Alright, I got...
Yeah, you're supposed to use the Groot one, not the...
Oh, shit, hey.
Oh, he stopped moving.
That's nice.
See?
All you gotta do is ask.
I think he's gonna ult me.
Oh, no, he doesn't have a...
What the fuck?
That guy just did a drive by.
Like, what was your plan?
the rocket there?
Okay.
Yippee!
Is that what it's like to win?
Oh no, if I start winning, I'm gonna lose in the tournament.
You can't let that happen.
Alright, I have a load here.
I forgot what that was like.
Winning?
Precision You know what?
I shouldn't have maxed that Hello guys I hope you're all
okay Alright Goodbye Oh shit Oh my god thank god for cleanse
oh goodbye No Wait we had no res It's okay we have Rocket Up
Winning what's that Alright
yeah bombardment is the best team up fuck i almost forgot
what that was like oh that would have been sick if i got
that that would have been sick if i got that prediction all
right i wish i know that anyone's streaming on the enemy
team just so i can like
that was that worth it oh all right rocket that's don't
worry rocket we're good that mag's whole purpose is just to
get frozen that's his entire job all right no spider-man why
did you rip him what what was the grip for I think it messed
me up.
It messed with my groove.
What was the point?
Oh, wait.
He did it.
Oh, my God.
He keeps messing with my groove right now.
I don't even know we're getting a portal in.
I don't think we are.
There we go.
Alright, that's fine.
It's okay.
Can't always count on Spider-Vets.
Okay, he should die, yeah.
There we go.
His entire job is just to be frozen.
It's just to be used as a freeze magnet.
I don't know why that raccoon is using the Acorn team up.
It's so bad.
Alright.
Oh!
My bad.
Fuck me, I guess.
Someone help him!
Please, he hasn't got his shots yet!
Oh, it's okay, their Luna died too.
Oh, or RTU's dead.
Wait, are rockets alive?
Hey, guys.
Oh,
my heroes!
My heroes, this is when you start grouping.
Oh!
What is going on?
Okay.
Alright.
It's okay.
I'm alive.
I don't know what's going on.
I will be right here.
I think our thing might...
Oh no.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
I don't know.
to do this but like i just actually i do b all right four
yeah keep beating keep punching three and this is where i
die this venom does not care he's like fuck her in
particular you know what maybe he's sexist i every time i
die he's he's sexist Oh my god, I want it to...
True.
I can't...
It's the only explanation, honestly.
I can't think of any other reason.
Okay, rack it.
There we go.
Alright, I would do it.
I am trying to help you right now like I can't help you that
much bro like if you I okay all right I'm pulling it out my
three hours of white fox I'm pulling it out just for you
rocket I just for you two hours of white fox tab pulling it
out chat this
is that moment
all right there you go we just need a push up all
right But hey, guys, there is a widow.
There we go.
I don't know what the plan is.
Nope.
Like, honestly.
There we go.
Look at that.
Now he's just cosmetic.
Now, look at that.
The Venom can't do anything anymore.
He's literally just cosmetic now.
Who would have thought?
Wait, you don't want me to pull out the white fox, sped him.
There goes my hero.
The final, if this is, if that's all I need.
Whoa, what is that word on my screen?
Victory?
You made this.
You made me do this.
Never seen that word before.
Oh my god.
What was that?
What was that word on my screen?
Holy shit.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
New word unlocked.
Never seen that word in my life.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I still feel the same.
I feel the same.
Not gonna lie.
Feels just like when I lost.
I got a little bit of victory on my gray carpet.
Yeah, just a little bit.
Is this wind breaking?
No, no, I'm going to go straight back to losing.
I'm just getting the losses out of the way.
You know?
I'm just getting it out of the way.
And then we'll see what it's actually.
Yeah, and then we'll win everything tomorrow.
high score did I break it a yellow stain I know disgusting I
don't know I'll play white fox I'm just you I literally
learn while I play I figure it out winning losing meets
nothing to an EOMM agent couldn't have said it better than
my wait that's
The thrill of it is just seeing how angry people are gonna
get.
I see no light.
It's just another day clocking in and out.
Surprisingly, I get yelled less off stream.
I wonder why.
Huh.
I can't see the pattern yet.
Oh, Dad's mad.
Like, Yuri has food.
He's just barking to bark.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
What the fuck?
He got closer?
He just thinks he's going to get extra treats.
That's it.
Everybody plug in your mic.
Life energy is a powerful weapon.
Hey, what?
I got 1,200 hours on him.
What?
Blade and trick on the other team.
Huh?
Alright.
Can we ban Punisher?
Can you bless me with a Punisher ban?
Alright, let them...
Let them do their thing.
Oh, man.
Yeah, I banned him.
You were right.
What's wrong?
What are we banning?
blade though what are we doing are using tracker who knows
everybody uses trackers except for me because i don't have
that i'm not important enough to be invited i already paid
for it i'm not paying for it what the next i'm sorry you get
it for free or you pay for it i'm not paying for a tracker
What is that?
But you got some yappers?
That's not good.
Oh, there is.
It's not good.
Because you don't know if we start losing, they're going to
start ripping it.
They're going to start ulting, but not in game.
Why?
Why use trackers?
People surprisingly really want to win.
I know it's crazy.
People really, really want to win.
You're going to use your second ult, the one that's IRL.
Oh, not using the...
Was it the Luna?
I don't remember what team Emma has.
What's a tracker?
Basically, even if you have your private profile, there's
trackers out there, either paid or you can also get it for
free.
Unfortunately, I'm not important enough to get it for free.
It's not like I would use it or anything.
Like, I don't have time to use it in game.
Like, people bad for me.
You think I'm gonna start batting shit?
Like, I don't... I tab out.
The time someone bans, I fucking just alt tab.
I'm not here to ban shit.
I'm here to play.
I'm a pussy
But basically if even you private your profile they can
literally see all the characters you play how many hours and
everything And so they can see if you're a one trick or not
So it doesn't even matter if you're in high elo even if
you're in high elo.
It doesn't matter everyone all the one tricks all the
streamers They got like they would hide their screen or in
all that shit, but it doesn't matter because everyone just
uses a tracker to bypass the bypass like the graphics where
they hide stuff
oh no is that a squirrel girl i should save my leaves they
have a dive
ah i don't do enough healing though all right nice Oh shit,
I hear...
I...
Wait a minute.
I nearly hear a squirrel girl and I'm fucking, I feel like
I'm going schizo right now.
I was like, where is she?
I hear her nuts.
I hear it.
Yeah, and being able to decide the bans, because it doesn't
matter, even if you have streaming mode on, the...
The trackers bypassed that.
Oh, what the fuck?
There we go.
I was like, what's going on?
Oh, shit.
She's in my wallet.
You know what?
I deserve that.
Streamer privilege.
Well, not- she's not staring for me, by the way.
She's not- she's not- Disclaimer.
She's not throwing for me.
It was just I'm just thinking I'm very lucky to be able to
have a free win Not because they're throwing for me, but I'm
not win trade.
I'm taking myself a hold I'm not win trading.
He just happens to be a bigger EOMM terrorist than me Show
your pay pal
Oh oh my uh we're just oh my god where are you please please
show me where you live oh fuck all right it's fine that's
good oh my god fucking queer superheroes oh fuck i don't
want him to start crossing my path.
Please.
Please start.
Alright, nice.
I mean, we just gotta destroy that.
Nope.
Where is the card details?
Alright.
Where am I ever?
What?
Where is I ever on the bounty list?
I don't plan enough to be bound.
The great thing about me being a variety is true.
streamers that I don't make enough and I don't play this
game consistently to make enemies they just don't know when
I start showing up the great thing is that I come in and out
every couple of months so they'll never know when to expect
yokey breed the elo terrorists
more hours that is such a lie no Oh, that is a...
I do not play this game every day.
I literally boot up whenever it's tournament season
sometimes.
They have a pros.
They play every day.
I wish we had.
I hope that my...
I'm just I'm too busy to play every day I do play like when
sometimes I do play when it's not tournament season oh oh no
that's not me you can have uh I only have two accounts
though
I took like a one, two week break, I think?
One week break?
One in the game?
Well, I know for sure who I'm avoiding.
What the fuck?
Guys, I can't do it, guys.
He has so much shields.
Oh my gosh.
I need to like, I don't play enough against...
I don't play enough.
Oh, it's spooky.
That's the guy on Rocky Raccoon!
What was I gonna say?
I already lost my track train of thought.
Whoops.
Oh my god, I wanted to save the dino.
I would play comp off that.
I wouldn't play quick play.
I lost my train of thought.
Because I got fucking...
ran at.
What was I talking about?
Oh my god, oh my god, patty cake, patty cake, patty cake,
patty cake, patty cake, we're
We didn't patty cake, we didn't, we didn't hit patty cake
Oh no, I was avoiding the squirrel girl, I need to say I'm
trying to remember
But I've got that extra lethal field Whoa, whoa, whoa, I
don't have enough leaves for you sir i wish i do wow wow
that's it let's go we go in oh my gosh she just kicked me
off that's fine nice that's just the key all right oh yeah i
don't yeah because like uh i don't play as consistent
anymore because i'm always so busy i do play whenever i have
halftime but even then i didn't play a lot i didn't play a
lot last season so i didn't whatever black cat was a thing i
didn't play it mostly i just got to eternity and then i just
stopped i did like a one week climb to eternity and i
stopped saying because like i didn't want to go against
black cat so i didn't learn how to play against black cat i
i did not want to learn i heard it playing
So I just, I played when Black Cat got nerfed.
Yeah, apparently it's so fucking broken.
So I played when she got nerfed at the end of the season,
whenever she came out.
And then, and then I just sped her in eternity and then I
clocked out.
That's really what I do.
Because I don't have a lot.
This is hell year for me.
So like when I do get a chance to play, I do play offline.
But I put like three to either like go do it all at once or
do my placements and then speed run to eternity or I play
like one or two days off stream get to eternity and then
clock out.
Okay, well we definitely have to avoid that guy.
Those guys like the rocket one trick.
Who was it on his?
He hated someone on the enemy team.
Who was it?
He was like, fuck that guy and just started throwing.
I don't even know who it was.
Nice.
I'll take it.
Free it, free, though.
Oh, doki, have a chill year?
Maybe next year.
Man.
Was it V7?
He fought with the V7 guy?
There's no V7s here.
Oh.
Oh, the game before that.
I thought you wanted to avoid the spooky guy.
I thought the spooky guy was the problem.
Blade one trick on the other team.
Blade one trick.
Alright.
Whoa.
How does he know?
Hmm.
Very suspicious.
It is.
I'll train for another hour.
And then I'll call it here.
And I have to walk dad.
And I have to...
I have to walk my dog.
He has really fucked up walking hours now.
Because he needs to follow my sketch we follow each other's
i follow his food schedule and in return he follows my
walking schedule life energy is a powerful weapon against
evil yeah it's equivalent exchange i get i get to pick
whenever i get to choose the schedule for walking and he
gets to choose the schedule for um for his food but who
suffers more I don't really play Jubilee because everyone
told me she's ass right now.
Like, she's not really good in rank.
Um, so there's no point in learning.
For me, there's no point in learning a character that's not
viable in rank.
Like my, like, you guys know how many supports there are in
this game?
Well not as much as DPS though, but still.
But she's so hot though.
But still keep hotness over practice.
Yes.
even though i don't hear as much oh what do you say but but
don't keep the battle starts in five are you going for a
poll first three three two one if you want to call the dive
i'll follow up i'll make sure
nice oh nice pull up do you want to go after the sport here
spidey
do something.
I gave you my leaves.
I got a daredevil looking after me, dude.
What the fuck?
Alright, well, I need to keep my leaves now for a daredevil.
Spidey, I'm on my way.
I should just...
Yeah, they're looking at me.
Whoa!
Fuck it.
Are you ready, Spidey?
Yeah, are you ready, Spidey?
Whatever you said, yes, I'm ready.
I don't think he's knows.
I don't think he knows.
Oh, there's a daredevil right here.
Oh, he doesn't have.
Oh, my God.
I can't see.
Jesus Christ, your soul.
Why did you wake him?
Why did you wait?
He was... That was our only chance to survive you gotta
understand you gotta stop waking them somehow no they woke
up dad still god jesus christ do not wake them do not to
live we have to be you cannot wake him Yeah.
Yeah.
Peace for art.
Oh, yeah, I'm coming.
I need...
Oh, God.
I need care on Angela.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Not again.
Not.
Oh.
Goodbye.
Oh, come on.
I I had a feeling I had a feeling oh no like I'm stalling
portal I can't portal it had to be Luna portal the Luna had
to portal it can't be me I have oh my god both our supports
could have gotten us back in there but instead we didn't do
that all right hold up for us no
I'm fucking...
It should be the Luno.
It shouldn't be me.
I was 58%.
Daredevil behind us.
Luno was zero.
She had less alt.
The rules of alt.
Whoever has the less alt charge has the portal.
It's the law.
We all know the rules of all charge I can't I don't have
another Is that law written in game?
It's literally It's literally written in law Is that the new
law?
All right, I'll go We are undefeatable.
Break the rock and roll.
Please pop the rock and roll.
No, okay.
What are you waving at?
Oh, no.
Goodbye.
This is where we die.
I tried to ban Grooves, but here we are.
They hit a checkpoint.
Now might be another time to stop them.
Alright.
It's the rivals.
it to play i'm i'm playing invis so this is how johnny feels
they have a mantis fruit that's just gonna be better than
what we can do the best bet i can do is that when they grew
up pray to god i'm not in it
i've had it too good for too long guys i won too many games
and that was like two games in fact why are we even why are
we going up whoa who does that benefit who like who that's I
want to know who does that benefit who does it benefit who
does who does wolf benefit i'm
still pushing
waltz first well it's time to find we wait who what did he
say who did she say who did she say guys who did she say
oh that's unfortunate for us oh
that's unfortunate I still don't know who the the wolf
benefits right now all right so we can have a raise the run
back there to the right Friends back there to the right.
I don't have a gun.
Oh Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
That's who it benefits.
That's who it benefits Don't worry.
Don't worry.
I have my brain.
Okay
The current floor is I I need a I don't understand.
How do they know?
It's not me, though.
I'm gonna leave you on red.
Always walk forward.
Alright.
I think we were really playing us.
It's not even dive at this point.
You know, I don't think Mantis is it.
Mantis again.
I don't think Mantis is good in this cap.
Cloak and Dagger.
Cloak and Dagger is so ass this season.
I don't know.
What?
That's not me.
I never play Doctor Strange.
I don't play Tank.
I'm not even talking about it.
I'm like super clear.
It's not the only part of me that's turned green.
I really should see a doctor.
I should really be going now The battle starts in five four
three two one I legit don't I think we're not gonna win but
because I knew winning two in a row was too much They were
like oh, that little the dinks though I I like that.
Those headshots though?
Oh my god.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, I thought they would walk forward.
Group wall.
I'm the other one shooting the wall.
No, I am too.
I'm just a support.
I know you know this, but supports don't do a lot of damage
against the group wall.
Unfortunately, that's my life.
all right i'm hitting it i swear to god i i swear to god oh
my god i'm almost have a let's go this is the only way we
are undefeatable oh my god this is not the only way here you
go Oh my god, the trees.
Dude, I just, I don't know what to do there.
You know, MMM strikes again.
Killer Patty, think of the 150s.
Guys, it's okay, I'm monetizing the pain.
It's okay.
I can't be truly suffering when I'm streaming.
I might lose imaginary points, but what I gain is monetary
value.
I monetize my pain.
It's all it's okay Make sure to shoot growth wall Make sure
Hey guys, are we shooting the wall?
Wait, kitty still doesn't have all It's true
It's okay guys Emma, could you keep me behind?
Yeah, I can do that Jesus Christ These people are positive.
All right, let's stand in front.
I hope people are...
Oh, yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh, where did he go?
Where...
Where did the pulse charge go?
I'm so confused.
Where did it go?
Don't worry, I know, I see the wall.
I see him.
That's fine.
We match!
We leave him!
Alright, that's fine.
Alright, now we lost.
Now, now we lost.
Again, I just, I don't know what to do for you, King.
Yeah, I think that's your deep, bro.
I'm making the right calls here.
It's okay.
It's not me.
I just, I just, it's just, you know, they were like, the
game was like, you know, who wins is a little too much.
It really is.
You know, I, fuck me, I guess.
It's fine.
Two wins was just too many too many and I get it.
I get it Life was too good That's the limit right there It
was too much it was punishment.
It was punishment for giving me a squirrel girl Blade one
trick and he rolls you all right Let him go blade he was on
10 when he was on blade Those tomb...
Yeah, tomb, that's suffering.
Saw the possibility.
What tournament?
I don't know this guy.
I don't know who this guy...
I don't know who this...
What this guy is talking about.
I just got off work at the hospital.
I'm gonna pee.
I'll be right back.
I got out of my nine to five.
Alright, I'll be back, guys.
I just got back from my nine to five.
I don't know what he's talking about.
I'll be right back.
I'll pee.
One day, if I get flamed, I won't be like, sorry.
I just got off of work.
The hospital.
didn't make it so i'm just trying to like i'm just trying to
like
try to cue cue it away and then just see how what they say
it is
and oh why don't we go triple support a powerful weapon
against evil now yeah i can't and then right now so i can
like not think about it yeah and i'll see what they say so
you realize the consequences of flaming
i wouldn't know what to say
just queuing to ease the depression away yeah so much the
patient didn't make it patient Yeah,
if your IRL healing is bad as in-game, I can see why I'm
playing support so maybe so I could actually save someone.
Is it also for hot?
I did not know that.
That it was just for therapy.
Well, then.
It's okay.
I have the enemy.
What hot?
I'm not saying what hospital.
This is my story.
in my make-believe story.
Yeah, patient confidence is for alive.
Exactly.
It's for people who are alive.
Don't worry.
Trust in this.
Triple support.
You didn't walk forward.
Alright.
A cloak and dagger player playing Starloid.
I don't know how much I can trust this.
Maybe you want too much.
the way it should be
I remember one time I wanted to be like if I get flamed I
want to be like sorry my wife left me sorry my girlfriend
broke up with me and just see what they the the battle
starts in five four three Just to see what they say.
I wanna know.
Could I leave it too?
I'm like, I know.
And I'd be like, she left me for my best friend.
Because RP ain't great now.
Oh shit, oh, I did not- Where was this fucking thing?
Oh, it's over there.
Sorry, I got distracted by my...
My role play.
I got distracted by my RP.
Okay, my team blew up.
LARP do me!
Yeah!
I...
Yeah, I got distracted by my...
my role play, guys.
My bad, my bad, my bad.
I'll focus up.
No more RP.
I'm getting ready for when they flame me.
I'm...
I'm just getting ready, guys.
My brother just died.
Sorry.
See that?
Hey, guys, we really gotta get rid of mines.
I think, like, that's the way to counter people flaming.
Just, like...
Unless you're there, actual psychopath, they would not care.
But, like, that's me worth betting on.
the fact that they have any sense of sympathy like oh nice
that's just me betting that they actually care body's on
point three on point they're not portaling they're not
portaling that's much better oh they're not portaling what
an interesting choice i don't know we're strong oh at least
you know it's nice to see if they like care or not or they
don't care you know what i watched this actually i shouldn't
I'm just hoping I'm gonna push card you got you go do your
thing Luna me being up here pushing card means that our Luna
will all first
You know what let's go
Oh shit all right maybe all right nice okay the wolf does
all right oh That's unlucky.
Oh, they were still Penny.
I'm surprised with that.
Yeah, they do have... I'm backing out a little bit.
Oh, yeah, that guy's not living.
So is him.
So, oh.
I mean, let's get off charge off that.
You know, I just want to test like human.
I mean...
Okay, what?
Oh, Wolf works now!
Okay.
I thought like the Wolf got fucking bugged or some shit.
Life energy brings me back.
Yeah, just to see like, you know, what's the word called if
people have a soul?
That's the theory of rival players have souls.
I'll do it right then.
Oh,
I need you guys to do your thing.
Because I don't have enough leads for this.
I still don't have enough leads for this.
Oh, my God.
I'm not looking that.
Yep.
I knew if I ulted, I just died instantly.
Dude, if you still want to do it.
Oh, we have death.
Daredevil against Penny.
I don't know.
But Mr. Banana.
Alright, let's give you speed.
I knew if I popped it.
I get mad at this.
I didn't want to test that.
You still want to do it!
Man!
If you still want to do it!
Fuck it, let's go.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I got... That's on me.
That's on me.
That's on...
I threw that.
It's okay.
I got my...
I got it ready.
I got it ready, though.
I'll be like, sorry.
My girlfriend left me.
It's everybody's everybody's girlfriends left them today.
It's okay.
We're all everybody's girlfriend friends left we're all
playing bad because of it guys yeah i'm not running it
straight in anymore right we got the nest though
i'm literally okay that's great oh shit There we go.
You can't run them over?
All right.
You guys are still winning this.
Oh my...
Just so like, I don't have to cross into it.
All right.
There we go.
I played it smart.
Yes!
there's no way i'm the only one shooting the wolf it's all
right there we go there was no way there was no way i was
shooting i learned though i learned from the mines i really
did i was like i'm not learning to happen again i mean i saw
the venue i was like no fuck that bro
it's okay We're all, all our girlfriends broke up with us.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Let's hope he doesn't...
I don't know where the nest is.
I'm so scared.
Bye.
Oh, I need so here.
it's just me it's okay I had I'm coming back I'm running oh
shit everybody's so low I don't like seeing that
oh my god okay I thought that was
back up back up he has armed and dangerous
Oh, who is he using that on?
Oh.
I really didn't even...
Oh my god, we're just so close.
Oh, don't stand near me.
Don't stand near me.
One of us dies and it's not going to be me.
Oh god.
Oh no!
I was 91.
2, 2, 0.
It's okay.
Switch things up, including which side you're on.
The right heroes could make all the difference.
Life energy is a powerful weapon against evil.
It's okay.
I might have someone that would come down that would suffer
with me.
That's okay.
I might got someone to fall into the pits of despair.
but like for him not me
I would say if a mag is ulting the two the supports have to
just split off there was no reason for Luna to run at the
same same area as me like one of us will have to has to die
we have to let the mag pick which one Like, the mag has to
decide on his own.
The 50-50 on that.
So I was like, I don't know why you decided to stand next to
me.
It had to be a 50-50.
The battle starts in 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
This is natural anger.
You need to stop that vehicle in its tracks.
You think he'll be okay?
Oh no!
Oh,
absolutely not!
I'm just gonna give him the damage right now.
Oh,
do you think he'll be okay?
No!
All right, all right, you and me I don't know if triple was
the play, honestly.
It might not be the play.
I have a feeling.
I think triple might.
Guys, it's not last season.
I'm gonna go back to DPS, babe.
Oh shit, we're portaling?
Somebody's asleep.
Yeah, I'm getting off triple.
That's a terrible idea.
I know!
I know it's a terrible idea.
That's what I thought, Tim.
I assume you're crazy, right?
Oh Not me
Not me I feel like I'm gonna die in this all that this is so
much damage
Oh my god, no, why me
Why was it only me shooting at the wall?
Hmm.
New perspective.
Why me?
Yeah, I know.
There was a lot of visual clutter.
Surely our Captain America's gonna...
Don't worry.
Back up, back up, back up.
He's still alive.
Technically, he's still alive.
a lot oh this is where we are good effort though on my end i
hit two headshots there peak of gaming dark i think it's
your tier one and stuff thank you thank you let's see you or
kill you all right
i'll take that wow
I'm dead What the fuck my platform My fucking I was I was
just like don't worry.
I have the high ground My high ground what happened?
What happened to my high ground?
Oh my god, he's so low you are three of your Okay, I have up
though.
I really don't want to use that.
Uh...
Oh, that's...
Let's...
I'm alive?
Honestly, safe.
I'm... I'm alive?
How the fuck?
Fuck did that happen?
Oh, not me!
Oh!
Stop!
I tried.
Oh my
god, I'm trying.
Oh my god.
This is the most I can give you.
I hope I... Also, this is why I don't like the cosmetics in
the for these skins don't because because like the Luna race
card cosmetic is so hard to see anything I swear to God the
Luna when the Luna alts I can't see shit like because of the
flags and everything in my fucking face like I guys can't
see anything Magvo Magvo Oh my god.
I swear to God.
Just so you know, I'm giving you...
I'm giving you the juice.
There is.
I put it on...
I don't have it on just the cat bomb.
I mean, I have it on default.
Like, default ults.
So I don't see all the effects.
I legitimately can't see shit.
I can't see anything.
Like the clutter.
The clutter is so hard to see.
Just in case.
Oh my god, he was.
I should have all that.
Oh, I gotta hit by that.
Oh my god, no.
Oh.
This is...
Oh my...
Bye yet.
All right.
Let's hope that he lives and let's hope that you live.
There's still a chance to stop them.
There's a piece there.
No, Luna!
Oh my gosh!
No,
I almost had all two.
Oh my god Luna if you live Luna if you were on the left side
with me Imagine how much how much dyno you all charge you
could have got They don't have this portal at the moment.
Oh my god.
She missed out on all the loot the dyno all charge
Oh that dyno all charge
Oh, that title!
Charge!
That she could have got!
Oh, no, I didn't.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
Okay, I'm gonna go for it soon, Manta.
If I can get some damage boost from you.
Okay.
Alright.
We go.
This is it.
All right.
There we go.
This is it.
We still have Luno.
We still have it.
Play it.
Make them walk into us.
Yeah, I'm playing this one.
Play it.
Oh, boy.
Nice.
We got it.
Oh, my God.
We did it.
That's how you do it.
a third win I've never seen that in light of day oh my god a
third oh my god what is that like
holy shit whoa slow down is that legal is that slow down
everyone whoa
well poor juke this is what i'm saying see if i think if
jubilee did not play jubilee i think it's more winnable
because i i feel like jubilee is just not that good this
season um you know she just got released
yeah three yellows oh slow down everyone no you can't i
can't talk about i can't guilt trip people rip it oh that's
madara he took my elo and i took his elo but it doesn't but
he took it from my main so it hurts more because when i was
playing on my main oh okay now it's not baby hours anymore
he loses more because he's higher i lose less and i gain
We're min-maxing.
Unintentionally.
Min-maxing.
I don't even realize my music was...
I forgot about the music.
It's unintentional min-maxing, guys.
I was gonna say, where the fuck's the music?
How am I supposed to jam?
Yeah, I play music on.
I always play music on.
I must have turned it off one day because I was tilted.
I always play.
Well, I can't say I've always played with music anymore.
Because usually people when they turn music off, it's
because they're listening to their own music while they're
playing.
But I don't do that because it distracts me too much.
I just want to listen to the game.
Because, you know, sometimes I jam.
You know when you jam too hard?
You know, you don't want to jam out too hard.
I just realized my nightbot timers are all off.
How am I supposed to show on Twitch?
Let's see.
All right, we got this one.
We got...
Buy my merch chill.
Like, my mods turn it off whenever I have a sponsor, but
then they always forget to turn it back on.
Sorry, I'll just show my game yourself.
ups in my merch.
Uh...
I'm not the type who fades quietly.
I'll practice.
I'm going to win this.
Actually!
Quietly into the background.
I want to chill.
Alright.
I've aimed too much there.
I say as I'm supposed to practice.
I spent too much time aiming.
all right let's play let's start gaming oh my god I haven't
had a duo in forever on stream
I haven't let people suffer on stream in so long you're
looking at tournament I'm just more worried about Sunday
just because I won't be there for the beginning the the
knockout games like i'm more concerned about sunday because
like tomorrow is just round robin it doesn't matter it's
just seating whoa
yay because my sub uh loses that would be so awkward Oh,
shit.
Wait, what happened to my res?
I didn't even realize my res got damaged.
He needs to play he or she needs to play one game, and I
have to hope to God they win that single Elim.
And I have to hope to God they win that one game.
So after the panel, when I come back, I get to keep playing.
I got the group team up.
The group team up is really good.
So it's...
Oh, lies on that.
Does he get respawned?
He does.
Yeah, I'm just hoping the sub survives.
Wait.
Oh, it's still tough, right?
Oh, he still is.
I believe in the Luna.
Yeah, see, I believe.
Is it double Elim?
I thought it was...
Oh, if it's double Elim, good for...
That's a long tournament.
Holy shit.
I didn't realize.
I thought it was going to be like a short tournament.
Usually a single Elim.
It's going to be a really packed week.
Every week is a really packed week for me.
Whoa!
That's five.
My Luna has all, and she's just going to match it.
See?
I believe in my Luna.
Alright.
I think they'll be fine.
I should start shooting.
I think that they're going to grow up.
So I'm going to stand further away.
And then so nice.
Okay, Justin.
Like, he could have almost killed all of us.
I'm just going to...
All I'm saying, that could have killed all of us.
That could have killed all of us.
That's...
Yeah.
It's double.
Okay, that's good.
So, like, the sub could take me to losers, and then I come
back and play losers.
That's fine.
But could it?
Yes, it could.
Oh, version will be updated in 60 minutes.
What are they adding in 60 minutes?
Oh, wait, is it?
Oh, it's the new skins, right?
Is it the new skins?
I can't even buy it on this account.
I have no money in this account.
Hello, Doki Burlington.
Alright, nice.
Here we go.
New map?
Wait, are they adding new maps?
Is it a rank map?
What map is it?
And more tricking...
What they needed?
do is add more characters who can twerk honestly i feel like
do they want more money and obviously they do with all the
goonerskins obviously let me cook they want even more money
imagine they add twerking emo to all and you have to buy it
all of them individually too and the thing is you have to
pay for each one of them individually you
That's all I'm seeing.
Alright.
Imagine that.
Hey, if it works on...
Oh my!
It's okay.
Katara came back.
Oh!
Let's go.
I contributed.
Wait, this game is easier when I'm on Rocket.
Why the fuck?
am i trying wow i remember why i play this video game now
oh my version's updated because you need oh you're right no
oh my god oh my god the map is moving
I thought she would all not me just let me go all right nice
I forgot you're right so I could practice the game oh my god
it's fine there's no way they'll shoot the res right I
should actually put I should reposition this, honestly.
Am I dead?
I'm dead.
It's okay.
My team will live on for me.
My team will live on.
I sacrifice.
Don't worry, catch the balls!
Catch it!
It's okay.
Catch the balls!
Okay, I might have thrown there.
If I healed the Luna, I would have...
Actually, no, I wouldn't.
Alright.
I think...
I think I can't play Rocket anymore.
Unless...
Alright, one more death.
One more death, guys.
I think I have to start trying.
I think for Grual, I have.
One death, one more death, one more death.
Sure, that one death wouldn't fuck us over, right?
Really?
I hope my team will be okay.
Honestly, I don't know how to get there to them.
I don't.
All right, I have to swap off, unfortunately.
I have to swap off.
I can't play.
I should have played Rocket because like we can get the res,
but it's okay
It's okay.
It's okay guys.
Oh shit.
It's not okay.
I just realized we're not 99 to 99 Maybe it's not okay.
Oh
Oh Oh, I don't Am I Am I okay?
There we go, there we go I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay I'm
okay Am I, I was just like Am I, am I gonna live?
Yippee Am I?
Yeah Am I?
Every time I play Rhylus, am I?
Am I okay?
Is this livable?
I don't know.
Alright, I gotta restart game.
I got my life flashed before my eyes.
I did not know how far...
How far it was gonna take me.
Oh my god, five wins.
Oh, this is the comeback.
I'm the comeback game.
Right here.
see you guys people who left early being like cheese did not
believe never leave it's like that England versus France
game guys I learned never clock out too early all right I
need to update the game real quick let's see what
the fuck who's
what the fuck is this guy someone was like there was a
google dokey that was dropped on some vtuber and they were
like hey be warned uh you collabed with him several times
and I was like who is this guy I've never they're like I'm
just like How the time are you sure like I do not recognize
this guy's name at all never seen this man before Who
You might have the wrong jokie All right, I'm updating I'm
at 1% This map cannot be like 200 gigabytes How many
gigabytes is this game again Guys I don't remember
I remember how many gigabytes like a lot I know I'm at 2%
what the fuck I have I'm downloading by 900 megabytes per
second right now there's no way of seeing this lot 13
gigabytes holy shit I better be like able to see every
single polygon on this map like the grass better be like
ultra hyper realistic um deal hdr on shit
see i gotta be able to see every single blade of grass
during on low i'm gonna i'm gonna get more tissue toilet
paper to blow my nose i'll be right back all right i need to
order more clinics boxes i ran out so i need a toilet paper
left i'll be right I'm going to order more tomorrow.
Doki's like, no, whenever I stream, it's just a streaming
thing.
When I'm streaming, I have a lot of, what's it called?
My nose is running a lot whenever I stream.
I think it's because I talk a lot.
And so when I'm talking, I don't know.
I don't know how this thing works, but it's just when I'm
talking.
I just have a lot of like, it's not even Flem.
It's just literally just running.
congested maybe i don't know i always have to blow my nose
um after like a couple of like an hour or two when it's
tournament guys it's in three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven it's a nine hours it's a nine hours i think i'm
getting good practice i think i'm doing pretty all right
honestly we're just not being the very best player streaming
this game i might be that i'm just apparently the happiest
player in this on this game um everyone yeah we're playing
in like like playing on an alt account and like in like
celestia i'm doing free i don't know that people are
enjoying it
i did debate if i wanted to if i wanted to like uh get my
main to one, because I was one game up.
I didn't want to, I don't know.
I just, maybe after this tournament tomorrow.
I think, like, after the tournament, see how I feel.
Because I didn't want to, I didn't want to grief team
players.
I guess.
I didn't want to, I didn't want to grief anyone.
I knew I was, like, not playing the best today.
So I was just like, Hmm.
I mean, I shouldn't grief people.
Yeah, I know it's 13 gigabytes, Madara.
I fucking know.
It's crazy.
I did grief.
I grieved.
Okay, I went even.
I went even.
I think I'm up one.
I grieved like four games on my main.
But it was technically even.
Madara can vouch for me.
I did well.
I should.
on you a bit you won but i i won the mental game i don't i
had the moral victory he won though but i had the more i i
then and then we my team won the next game uh yeah my my
team won the the second game i went against madara but he
was on his alt account so it didn't like matter to him like
i was on my main.
You denied me my C1 rank up, by the way, Madara.
When will you play on your main with me?
I want...
When will you play on your main with me so I can also deny
you top 500?
See, look, coward.
He's a fucking coward.
He's a coward.
He's afraid.
Don't do it, Vatara.
That's what she wanted.
She's trying to...
No, don't say that.
I'm just saying he's a coward.
That's what she wants, Vatara.
Don't do it.
She's just baiting you.
It's like the Breaking Bad meme.
All I'm saying, all I'm saying is that he doesn't trust, he
doesn't believe in me.
Isn't that fucked up, guys?
Romado froze.
Did it?
Oh, whoops.
The update went so hard that I crashed.
Give me a sec.
Let me fix that.
I literally crashed because of the patch.
Let me boot that back up.
Let's see.
Madaya, why do you think I'm always streaming solo?
Why do people only play with me off stream, Madaya?
Don't connect the dots.
It makes two, don't connect the dots.
All right, let me grab it real quick.
hmm that's pretty weird
that's a lie i solo queue a lot too all right i solo queue
off stream a lot dude that's a lot
all right i'm waiting give me a sec oh my god my seam is
fucking going the patches uh how long does it take to get
celestia well i had did plays I placed in Celestio 2 for
this season.
So it's not too bad.
It's just if you have time to do your placements, it's like
what, 2 to 3 hours?
How many, I think, is that 10 games?
2 to 3 hours?
Maybe 3 to 4?
I don't know.
Sorry about Steam.
Yeah, it's a new map.
I wonder if they, are new maps instantly in the, are they,
Instantly in the rotation, because I know in Overwatch, they
don't do that in Overwatch.
They give you a little breathing period.
I don't know if they let it rip straight into rank.
Oh my god.
My YouTube studio does not like Marvel Rivals patching or
any.
Starting a rotation.
All right, we're going to learn it live.
Are you excited, Madara?
Are you fucking excited?
Wait a minute.
Oh, wait.
We're both on our alt account, so it doesn't matter.
We're doing it live.
He's on his alt account.
All he's losing is his ego.
Completely black screen.
Yeah.
I'm still patching.
Yeah, all he's losing is his image.
That's it.
Also, Killer Squirrel, thank you for gifting a tier one sub
to Jubilee.
Thank you.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Give me a sec.
Everything is so slow right now.
You're in?
I still have, like, 20, 30.
I'm 82%.
Maybe I should not have booted up VTube Studio while I'm
still patching.
Maybe that was a bad idea.
Hmm.
Well, I never learned.
That's a great thing about me.
Because I know eventually it'll work.
You bash your head against the wall enough times the wall
will eventually crack.
or you die someone just has weak head weak head game that's
your strongest weakness
not if you have if you have a weak head game yeah
I would do more gorilla twitch streams if I wasn't like
going through hell year right now it is a little better now
that the concert is over but like um it's so yeah that's not
the greatest yeah no that's not true I thought last year was
hell year now I realize this year is hell year no next year
will be easier I I bet next year's gonna be easier guys it's
gonna next year's gonna be easier why I might I'm still at
86 I'm gonna off v2c is maybe that'll be better it went up
all right let me i know what to do give me a sec where's my
foogie
um oh shit i'm just gotta make sure my obs doesn't oh oh oh
i hope i'm still streaming
I hope...
Oh, oh, I am?
Oh, okay.
Alright, that's good.
My OBS sort of froze.
My OBS might have froze just now.
Alright, I'm not gonna play with anything on my OBS.
That is a little scary.
I'll just...
I won't touch anything.
It says two minutes remaining.
I'm a 91%.
I'm a 91%, guys.
I mean hey We get to experience the new map too Oh my god
Let's go What good timing We get the new map as well
Okay 92 It's a new map I don't know I'm not captain I'm not
reading the room I actually I show up I play the game Look I
show up I reading the rules is for cat is a captain's job
that's not it's not my job i didn't even know i didn't even
know that uh that we had an elimination round yeah
look my it's my team's responsibility i i'm just here to
listen guys i show up play my role I pray I don't die in
game like if it goes if we're playing a new map we play the
new map it's a lovely surprise during the tournament I mean
it was a very lovely surprise to find out that even if my
sub fucked up when I'm gone I still at least get to play
after and then I can fuck up and get us eliminated you know
like if we're getting eliminated I it better be me
eliminating my team you know i'm not i'm not outsourcing it
to myself i want to be the one that take us out yeah it
should be my job not that i would not that i would it's
unintentional you know yeah we're going down on my terms Not
that I would I'm not intentionally throwing If we're getting
eliminated I go down with the ship With my team I'm 98% Yeah
I'm not letting them kill steal What the fuck Damn right
Alright Alright check out Madara Wait Madara you stream now
right I saw I was watching you stream a little bit
Don't be that...
I always try, Gomez.
You know I always try.
It's just sometimes I get really unlucky.
I always try.
Allegedly.
I do.
Not allegedly.
It's true.
All right.
Oh, yeah.
I still have the Nikkei.
I keep forgetting to take that off.
Zed, they give a tier one, so they give a thank you.
Alright, I can boot up Rivals now.
I need to, the only big, the only problem is just what I
hate about it is the fact that I have to also, let's see,
redo everything.
My Rivals always boot up on my second monitor, so I have to
like reposition it every time.
Alright.
There we go.
It's very annoying.
Alright, I'm back.
Look at this.
I want to see a magic trick.
Abracadabra.
Sorry, there's ping issues with my magic trick.
There.
Sorry, my magic trick has ping.
What do you mean?
Whoa!
I was lagged.
My magic trick has lag.
The witch.
Alright.
Back.
Oh yeah, Gomez isn't a streamer anymore.
He's a fucking norm.
Oh no, he went back to Overwatch.
He's a normie and he fucking plays over...
He's an Overwatch player.
And you know how much of a normie he is now?
playing rivals competitively he got a driver's license he
doesn't play the game put competitive anymore to the point
where he learned how to drive God forbid yeah
but the fact that when he was competing when he was
competing he never bothered to get a driver's license a
driving license and then when he started competing uh and
when sorry when he stopped competing he he started learning
how to drive hey i have a driver's license too you know it's
crazy um also pretty dangerous so there's a new law in fact
in canada where uh usually in canada you have to do get do
two licenses licenses where uh you get your new driver's
license and then after a while you had to take the test
again to get like your to get your uh uh experience driving
license but they're making a new rule that they're
indoctrinating soonish where if you've been a new driver for
if you've been a new driver for more than what was it 10
years or i don't know i don't remember it was like eight
five years more than five years, your new license can
automatically be upgraded to experience driver's license.
But the thing is, I haven't drove a car since I first got my
driver's license.
So technically, I won't do it.
But they would grandfather my license as an experienced like
driver.
do it obviously because that's dangerous but technically i
could yeah i got the license to use as an id yeah so because
i had the new driver's license for more than six plus years
uh perhaps more than eight plus years um i can get
grandfathered in as an experienced driver just because i've
had it for a while because you're like if you had it for
more than five plus years or some is there like well
technically they had so much experience driving so like
there's no point in doing another test due to the fact that
they already drove so much and i'm like yeah yep that's me
true that's me that's their reasoning
i'm ready I drove so much in- I think like my experiencing
misuse driving in-game clearly reflects very well to how
it's gonna be like in real life I drove so much doesn't
matter in-game
10-year expert if you can honestly it's almost a 10-year
expert.
I forgot that Lan is this week for rivals, right?
It's this week.
I should I want to stream more on Twitch.
Like, I want to do more guerrilla streams on Twitch playing
rivals.
It's fun.
I just like hanging out with you guys.
What's the point in the rank license?
You get, what do you mean, rank license?
I just fun today.
Just chill.
I don't like games that I stream on Twitch.
I just stream like competitive games.
I don't like streaming like story games or anything on
Twitch because I'd rather have it on YouTube just for VODs.
And one day I will remember to upload Twitch VODs onto our
Twitch VOD channel.
I need to delegate that.
One day.
I know there's a Dragoon out there that has been keeping my
Twitch VODs archive.
Shout out to that one Dragoon out there that gave up on my
Twitch VOD channel.
and started archiving the Twitch bots themselves.
Shout out to you.
I will reach out to you soon.
TM.
Grab all the Twitch bots I've missed out on.
Why are new and experienced lights?
Because when you're a new driver, when you're a new driver,
you have to get a new light.
The license has to be a new driver.
And you have to put on your car that says you're a new
driver.
Just because, like, So people would know, you know, you just
got your license and everything.
And then after that, you have to be considered to be able to
take off the sticker that you're a new driver.
You have to do another test to be considered.
Oh, shit.
I think we're going to lose.
Not, we can't even lose on a new map.
Like, we can't have nothing in this world.
We can't have anything.
Not only that, there's three top 500 players on the enemy
team.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
I can't even lose on a new...
What's the point?
I can't even lose on a new map as well.
Can't have nothing good.
But yeah, like, so to be able to take off the new driver
sticker, you have to do another test.
You have to do another...
No.
They rejoined.
The game wouldn't give...
The game wouldn't be that good to me, guys.
Okay, this is Marble Rivals.
You think...
You think the game cares?
Guys.
I always...
I even missed out on the season...
What season is this?
Nine?
The season nine sponsored Twitch...
Oh my god!
Wait!
Don't do this.
Don't bait me again, bro.
Don't...
Don't you fucking do this to me.
We're so back.
It's over.
We haven't streamed for four hours.
Has everyone got their sprays yet?
I don't know.
I do wish that they do.
You're a top-notch team to win this one.
Oh, we didn't even ban a second character, bro.
What are we doing?
um oh my god this guy has champs already for what did i just
see i saw so many things animated and lorded i do think
twitch drops could be improved a lot they give us like money
like the not money like every time you watch uh the stream
you get paid 20 no i'm saying i mean like um like the the
in-game the what was it the molecule shit or whatever yeah
the blue one
oh my god I was gonna say why is the robot just tweeting on
captain America
I'm gonna remove it the moment he leaves.
Okay, he does not watch it so he doesn't know.
Wait, no, but then he'll stop playing with me.
I can't do that.
I have to make sure he plays with me on his main before I
start fucking him.
Fucking with him.
All right.
Nice.
I want to take away his...
Oh, shit!
I want to take away like the...
Take away the snowflake when he's on his main then because
then he lose he won't be ranked 30 anymore
Yo, get your mana together.
It's 2 30 in the morning
Guys, he's won!
I'm sad Oh shit, whoops
Oh.
Where's my widow?
No!
Please!
Okay, I should just go fuck with that.
You ever...
I've had this problem when I'm typing stuff, but I always
like forget like, because I like type faster than I think.
I think that's like, what's the word?
Like...
So like I would have oh Shit So like every time I type and I
reread it I would like I would be missing like words in my
sentences like one or two words in my sentences But I like I
swear to God I wrote it though
Jesus Christ guys, I don't know we win this.
Oh my god He'll eat one of us, but it won't be me.
I'm eating bro.
Good luck to me Wait, you should weigh all that.
You should.
Hey.
Ah!
I thought I should have went right.
I didn't see where my dino is.
Advice on how to play Luna Snow?
Maybe I'm not the right person to ask this.
I don't know I don't know if I'm the right person to ask
this right now I'm killing everything bro fucking help me
this guy's not my friend's list I don't know how he got on
my friend's list I actually I don't know I don't know who he
is oh massive whale though Oh, nice.
I don't know who he is.
I legitimately, I've been trying to figure this out.
I'll tell you, I'll tell you guys, besides all my mains,
friendless.
I, I don't, I don't know who he is.
But like, he was like, guys, I've been winning every game.
Like, check my, check my profile.
Check my profile.
And I swear to God, I saw, oh my God, is this Sakura?
Is this?
And I saw 20 game losses in a row.
Wait, this is the camp.
Oh shit, I could have saved him.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, but I...
I fucked up.
Yeah.
And then I saw 20 losses in a row.
And because he's like, guys, I've been winning every...
Like, he was on my team and he's like, guys, I've been
winning every time.
I don't know why we're losing here.
And then he's like, check my profile.
Check my profile.
I was like, I was like, huh, man, is it us?
Is it me?
Just to find out?
Okay, I'm locking in.
I'm locking in.
That was my bad.
My bad.
Okay.
All right, I'm locking it.
I'm locking in.
All right, now I know it's secure, though.
It makes more sense, knowing that this is secure.
The hall.
Not me, at least.
Oh, my God.
I didn't see the shield.
I didn't...
That's...
Alright.
I'm locking it.
This time I'm locking it.
I'm locking him.
I'm so fat.
I'm so big.
I can't get up.
Wait.
Let me...
I don't know if his profile is still public, but...
Because I was like, bro, he's still playing.
What are you saying?
Because I don't know if he's still...
Don't you got him, please.
Don't you got him.
I don't know if he's still...
If his profile is still public.
but i don't know if he's recovered because he did not he was
playing like the whole i i feel like he was online the
entire one two days oh holy bro
i texted you yesterday to play you didn't respond you texted
me when i was asleep brad i don't even know who he's talking
about both okay I'm locking it yes I think I know why people
like playing with me off stream I think I'm figuring out why
whoa all
right it's five oh my let's go let's go a mess it's five
it's five
Oh It's no longer fight.
Oh It's no longer fight
What the fuck did
I?
Oh my god He's mad because we have a one-year anniversary on
this score No, it's fine.
What gives you that idea?
I'll give it to our widow
Oh, please let me see you.
I'm so scared.
Oh my god.
I don't understand.
So why do people like playing with me off stream?
I think I'm trying just as much as I do.
on stream I'm scared perfect
precision oh hey save me dokey bird y'all he can't let my
own boy just don't get on fire I'm gonna cry okay
Oh my god.
What are we still waiting on?
Save him.
I was like, gosh.
The right heroes could make all the enemies.
Like a moon, I shine in darkness.
What you missed out on.
What's going on?
She's doing awesome.
How did they just type?
Oh, I thought I was like, oh, no.
I had to eat a couple of crying.
If only so, she had someone step aside, princess.
I'll handle this.
Step aside, point sis.
Wow, why are you trying to play for?
Even the ocean of sunrise does not be as bright as you,
Emma.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
What are they about to say?
Why mute?
What's gonna happen?
Someone's gonna all.
Someone's gonna fucking all.
They're gonna alt, guys!
Mute the chat.
You know that something's gonna go down when they tell you
to mute the chat.
I feel it in my heart.
bones and they're gonna oh oh
my god yo kill that big one we can kill the group no i wish
i could
oh my god at least they warned you don't worry me and derek
can murder people in that someone needs a snowball in the
face fear best self a shortcut to space ah where is he
oh oh no i'm scared right now perfect for safe
why what even happened to me i don't even I don't even know
what happened to me.
I'm coming back.
Oh no.
Alright.
I feel like this is you inside.
This is us inside.
Doki's brain.
Cam and Dori wanted to play.
We're both on health accounts, so.
It's fine.
Oh shit.
I think they have Jubilee all.
Don't worry.
I have.
Oh my, it's five.
I'm gonna grab the group.
Hey, look how it's Jubilee Jubilee.
It's five.
Oh,
I hope I can't.
I'm shooting it.
I'm shooting it All right
Oh shit wait who's What did you guys what?
How did my how did my freeze it didn't hit it?
You guys saw that right?
Oh my god.
What is going on?
I don't have all, I can't eat it.
Oh my god, I grabbed him in again.
There is still a widow right behind us.
I don't know.
Was that a self-shoot?
I was just like, what happened?
Yeah, that's a weird...
That's a weird Groot skin, Madara.
Is that a new one?
Groot's bad here.
What?
That didn't hit?
Come on!
I'm clapping.
I'm doing my job.
I'm clapping still.
I'm be clapping for the rest of my life I'm gonna be
Oh my god, I got pushed off.
I got pushed off
Yeah, you got to run the jet team so you can heal me That's
a problem.
Oh, bye.
I clapped as long as I could!
Nice.
I take those.
You know, I take those.
Break that big wall.
Break that big wall and the Groot dies every time.
Look at the Groot is still alive.
I'm being lied to because the Groot is still alive.
I don't know who's ulting first.
Not me.
Okay.
As long as it's not me.
Nice job.
Awesome.
I'll match it.
I match.
No.
I clap, I clap.
I clap.
I'm clapping.
I'm doing my job.
They still have rocket amps.
actually they don't have yet they don't have yet oh my god
we could maybe honestly go with this i can bob my god i'll
clap again i hope that's i don't know if this is a good ult
guys i i have a feeling that might not been the smartest ult
that we could do
Oh You back up I can pop you off Holy shit looking brutal
right now
Goodbye, goodbye Goodbye We have two for it Okay, we should
rock it I almost have a little Bruh Just don't die, don't
die right now, just say okay Oh, I fucked it up break that
big one drew died kill drew three two one kill drew oh he's
one hp he's one hp you can die kill him no no hey i'm
watching i'm watching wait i'm gonna all we need uh you have
to use i'm gonna die i'll build i think i'll build it down
to 30 seconds shoot the big one
five oh my god oh my god no okay we have luna in five funny
get off cars we have luna in five i'm ready to put oh god
funny you're like frontlining way too all right three uh two
no hold me that's unlucky push.
Keep the dinosaur alive.
We won't have fun all.
No!
How did he know I wanted to go left?
I think there's a widow behind.
Oh my god.
He's so smart.
Your current score is three.
I get glass.
Red like a buck.
He did.
You'll need a top notch team to win this one.
Red me.
He fucking knew what I wanted to do!
I'm Luna Snow.
Like the moon.
No, Luna's really- Vision's really good.
He's on- I don't remember what team he's on.
He's on a team.
I don't know where he is.
I don't know.
Oh, but oh, he's the, yeah.
I just don't know.
I just know when, if people are in the team or something.
Because they're on triple support.
The guy lives forever.
I mean, I was talking about the Wolverine.
I'm not gonna lie.
That's pretty good, no?
It's good to see.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
damn all right here we go yeah i don't know how you're 29
and 10 and their widows 44 and 6 that's a problem you really
are asking barcodes to roll you in the middle no no this is
you don't understand barcode is that if you did you
understand if you did who could you beat who could he be
we don't know we don't know who he is
she doesn't agree with the whole fucking round people down a
lot
i'm gonna walk in i'm gonna start clapping I Think I think
our widow might be getting diffed guys just a maybe
I think I think he might be getting diffed
If he's with the girl and break it pushing with them all
three two one Oh
I grab her again.
Please kill Jubilee.
Guys, I have another chance.
Kill her.
She fought her.
She's not moving.
What?
This is real firepower.
Guys, did we kill her?
Did we kill her?
Did we kill her, guys?
Did we?
Did we kill her?
No, I'm not even trolling.
Did I rock at all?
Just save them the game.
Three, two, three.
Time to switch things up.
Guys, do we...
Do we...
Do we kill her?
I don't know.
Do you think we killed...
Do you think we killed the...
Killed Jubilee?
Oh my...
I'm tempted to go Rocky.
Oh, Lord Warlock.
Yeah, you cute with the Sky Widow?
No, I saw it.
This isn't even my account.
I didn't mean to play this game.
Yo, do you think this guy's just dying to the chat?
What?
Is it...
Wait, is it Nug?
It's getting fucking weird tonight.
I don't know.
His name is familiar.
Is he pro or not?
That's familiar.
Or is he just a grinder?
Yeah.
They'll be coming in 30 seconds.
I don't remember.
That's a...
Oh, he's not active, right?
It's fine.
I mean, it's not fine.
But he can't get dropped for a...
Technically, I don't know.
That's not like Rivals Rivals is more lenient when it comes
to Threatening people If it was Overwatch That's like If it
was Overwatch, that'd be like Because they fucking find
people for Pepe's But
They're much more lenient on what you can say And can't say
I don't know Try to throw snowballs with me though If it was
Overwatch, it would be like...
Oh my god, you put those...
Alright.
Where's her widow?
She's about to be playing that.
She's not late.
She's up on the right, on the right.
I'm getting marked on the right.
Oh my, every tap!
Widow top right here.
Widow main now.
Who even has...
Mag, mag, mag, mag, and mag.
Look at the back on, look at the back on.
Oh my.
I don't even know.
I have to reload.
I have them all.
Keep feeling that.
Here, kill the tank, kill the tank.
This is real firepower.
Oh my god, what's going on?
If I run through Sam right now, we end the video game.
Nice shot.
I'm gonna kill the group running it down Ruchel ran it down
Perfect Preston I'm gonna play with them as you The crew
wanted me to get my Disappear Oh my god It's me No No No No
No Go go go go We're all res Everyone touch point.
We're all red.
Born again.
Three, two, four.
Oh, my God.
Well, you can't expect to win them all.
He was not born again.
Team instantly folded.
I'm trying.
It's not about you heal so much.
I heal.
You heal so much.
How am I... If you siphon all the heels, how would I get the
heels?
I... All I did...
All I do is clap and I swear to God, I feel like I
haven't... I've been non-stop left-clicking.
How would I get fed?
Just clap harder.
All I get is scraps.
i i feel like i'm begging for food here if only i just walk
forward i swear to god i feel like i've just been pumping it
in non-stop and clap more
yeah also mad just kept soloing me it's my bad it's my bad
sorry what Like, I'm being fed scrap of it.
I should have clapped more in a way where, like, the enemy
was in front of me.
But, like, it's just so high.
It was so high.
I felt like I was getting denied non-stop.
It's alright.
Oh, yeah.
Let me show you guys.
Oh, wait.
He started winning again.
Oh, there.
Yeah.
Okay.
So, there was, like, it was, he, he hasn't stopped.
Look at the timestamps.
It got, I think this was, maybe it's around here.
Or you might see me.
Or it could be the day before.
Because I was so confused.
I was like, who is a true tank?
Because he kept telling us to check his profile.
And I was just like, why?
Yeah, it's not here.
It's past this point.
It's past this.
It's...
It's past here somewhere.
He hasn't stopped.
I got a little concerned.
At least now I know who it was.
I was so confused, because he's on my main.
He was like...
He was like on my friends list on my main.
And I was like, who is this person?
Now I know it's Sakura.
I just wanted to see the new map.
I don't want to experience the new map.
Yeah, his girlfriend broke up with him too.
That's why I didn't build my own.
My patient died in the hospital.
So I couldn't focus my bad.
Oh, I should have said that.
I should have wrote.
Ah, I should have wrote that.
I was just like, I felt like I was being fed scraps.
I should have.
I was like, sorry.
My girlfriend dumped me.
So I'm just trapped.
I'm going to ease the pain.
Yeah, but when I experience it in rank, I think it's more
fun as a little surprise.
Deaf versus breakup.
I don't know.
And my girlfriend dumped me in the hospital that I work at.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
And then my patient died, too, on the same day.
So, like, that's why I'm playing Rivals at 3 in the morning.
What's your experience?
like what's your excuse for playing three in the morning
I'll do that that's a good one that's a good RP my
girlfriend yeah my girlfriend dumped me before she died
because I had because I I made sure I just accidentally I
accidentally Zenly did not come to call.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
And my girlfriend dumped me and then she died.
Specifically in that way.
In that way.
Shout out to...
Wait, what's this?
Shout out to is like the pro coach that said I was playing
really good.
I think he was lying.
that first game i was just i was like it's it's okay i'm
used to losing you don't have to glaze me oh fox came fox
came in and was like you're doing really good it's like it's
okay i'm used to losing you don't you don't have to lie i
literally did not know what was going out during that first
game i was not locked in please yeah we're reality you got
top we all saw how i got to top 200 like do you we all saw
how clueless i was how i was screaming 50 of those games out
of confusion uh zarius think of the twitch prime thank you
thank you i don't even know how that was possible Pick your
hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
That's right.
But then people who see the screenshot on Twitter, they're
just like, Whoa!
She's so good.
And I'm like, Yeah.
Let's see.
Alright.
Sorry, my mama messaged me.
No, I'm part of it.
uh to like bring new outfit stuff get ready what oh shit
nice wow no fun it's all right what the is going on how do
they know how do they know though wait a minute wait how did
how did they know that was our plan all this all along all
right i forgot mantis i felt like i was playing luna for 20
years i forgot what character i was
all right goodbye mr fantastic i hope you don't die
goodbye mr fantastic i hope you live
He's still alive.
Anyone shoot the thing, he's alive.
What about the...
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying.
I swear to God.
Someone had to die eventually.
Jesus Christ.
Was for days.
Oh!
No!
Actual walls for days!
Oh shit, it's...
We're against them.
Oh.
Maybe that'll hit someone.
Yeah!
Always let it ride, guys.
Maybe you will hit someone.
But then maybe I'll get hit.
you think it's winnable you think this is you know what
okay i think i'm just gonna chill out here i think i'm gonna
swap off mantis yeah i'll use my own and then i'll swap dps
like what are we doing what are we doing Don't worry.
This will work out.
All right, it's time.
I've hit the stage where I go rocket.
In hope for something.
I'm at the point where I go rocket.
Me rocket.
Oh my god, she's still there.
I didn't even see her to be fair.
I actually did not realize she's so tiny on my screen She's
that she was so tiny on my screen.
I didn't even notice that was her.
I legitimately was like oh my god That tiny guy was little
What I hear I hear a thing
all right i'll just be here i'll just be here guys i'm
existing i'm existing i'm existing here i hope i'm
positioned correctly i might not be honestly
that's not fair
hope our invis is okay i don't know where she is oh there
she is I didn't say where did she go yeah I can
whoa hey guys oh my god I'm I'm trying to find you oh okay
we're gonna
Just keep breaking walls.
Oh god.
Oh no!
Well we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
We got on.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh god, okay, okay, I was gonna...
You're welcome.
and
go through please no one went everybody's too fat everyone's
so fat
damn i'm gonna go outside it's actually okay here oh shit
madara playing fps oh shit I don't even know if I should go
Luna.
I'm at the point where I might have to just go Br-Rocket.
Br-Rocket.
I was just like, where am I going?
What freak have?
The battle starts in five, four, three, yeah, you can see
them.
Oh yeah, we're going back to the topic.
You can see some crazy shit.
I think there's like, I think like rivals just doesn't have
like rival pro teams a lot of players haven't gone through
like PR training but like also I think it's also because
like you know because you know how you don't really get
punished so so there's no I think there's like no reason to
get PR training
Yeah, Ashlyn.
Because PR training is money.
And like, you know, why are we wasting money when you don't
get punished for it?
That's just a waste of money.
It's a lawless lad.
Truly is.
Maybe I shouldn't have it right here.
It's alright.
It's not like that.
They won't know.
Oh, shit.
What do you got?
How are they going to know?
No, I hope we live.
We don't live.
Look at the cloak.
I thought everyone.
Oh, that's like, in what, 10 hours?
Oh, I should.
Time is it.
All right.
It's all right.
We have my ult, which is very strong.
I hope this isn't at three in the morning.
Imagine the tournament ran all the way to a three in the
morning.
It's an eight hours.
But we can't end on a loss, though.
The next...
Okay, the moment we win, we can be freed.
Oh, my God.
Dad's angry.
I think we'll be fine.
We'll be okay.
We'll be fine.
Let's go.
We're not gonna shoot.
Shoot my ult.
here maybe they should oh no that's angry that's i have to
get rid of my res here he has uh oh no he's so angry it's
okay there's no way they see this oh there's no way it's
bait i can bait it get baited get baited you got baited with
my oh dad is mad that is mad it's okay it's okay Give,
please!
I need to get my...
Oh no, he's getting louder!
I just realized my res does not have a lot of HP.
Okay.
Oh, fuck!
We're gonna blame Datmas!
Hey!
No!
Give me like one more- Okay.
Things are gonna be different this time.
I'm gonna try to stun the- I actually don't know how it
works.
Oh.
He's not gonna do it.
Okay, look guys, I lost that because of this was my dog's
fault.
It was my dog's fault
This was I will say this is my dog's fault if we lose I got
Friendly fired What the what?
Oh, hey, welcome back.
You like your little.
Oh, that guy has uh Oh, that guy definitely has a...
Surviving?
He's alive.
Why me?
Oh, I'm not gonna make it easy.
What did I do to deserve that?
They're just gonna walk it.
They're not Portland.
I'm just a little... Oh, it's Sakura.
That's why I'm here.
They're falling, they're falling, they're falling.
Back up, they're falling to point.
I don't have a lot.
You're gonna...
It's why I'm...
It's okay.
I'm nuking him!
I should hit him, right?
I should be expendable, please.
Please, I'm just a little guy.
I'm just...
I'm just a little guy.
Lock in for you.
Dad.
As I swear, I'm trying.
I ain't sure I like the way you're looking at me, fella.
I swear to God.
Are you out of your flock in mind?
Go on.
No, I haven't yet.
I wanted to see the new map.
It's convoy, right?
Hey, wrong door guys.
Come over here.
It's alright.
Uh-oh.
Whoa.
I'm listening.
One.
to do is capture the mission area okay well fuck that guy is
he not in voice he's not in voice okay three two one
oh my god it worked it worked guys
okay good deal bad um where are we where are we Oh my god
fucked it up.
See back up see back up.
I fucked it up.
I fucked it up guys
It's okay It's okay that we got point we got point despite
the eyes
Is this thing like a human
It's okay.
I'll be the one to shoot.
We did not need that.
I got scared.
Whoops.
It's okay.
We have Sewell.
He's just fucking running every time I see him.
It's okay.
We have Sewell.
In the middle back here, there's going to be a hell of a...
I'll patch you up.
Good medicine.
I'm alive.
Oh, the Gruta's looking for it.
He's looking for the Kobe.
He's fucking looking for it right now.
He's...
He's so unhoused.
Can you hold me?
He's lo- I'm looking backwards, really.
I don't know!
I just see a fucking Groot slowly walking towards me.
Like...
The slow walker, get him out of here!
I get him out!
He's gonna touch me!
Good thing.
I think we're ulting our fucking...
He wants to touch me!
Seriously, stay away from me!
Can't beat a thick coat of foot.
Nowhere yet.
Going to overtime.
Oh no.
Can we play slow?
Wait, where's the stairs?
Where's the stairs?
I don't know if he makes it.
He makes it.
There we go.
I think we're up with the portal.
There's no magic plus rocket.
Care thing all in this corner.
Alright.
Care hook?
No hook.
all right push with rocket three two one
that's cool you can only play the ball yeah
did we do okay back up back up they used like everything oh
it's okay it's okay it's okay
It's okay.
He wasted all his nerve is he wants to be on stream.
That is his greatest weakness His greatest weakness
His greatest weakness that he wants to be on stream All
right Good, good, good fall.
So Groot is time washing.
We need to break these football
Oh my god.
Nice.
Push, push, push.
Don't fall.
But yet.
Walking heals.
I'm saying, thank, thank, thank.
She was healing me.
Ending was hurt by the way.
I'm on point.
I'm going to catch a portal.
I'm on track.
Oh my god.
Something really is happening.
Careful portal though.
Just carry.
Oh my god.
Is someone.
Something happening?
No.
Going to overtime.
The hell is that?
We can win.
They only have one score.
Oh my god.
This is real firepower.
Yo, why are you so old in our rocket so that you can fall
for instance?
Okay, good.
But it's okay, we won.
It's okay.
He canceled the alt.
He canceled.
He all canceled, guys.
He all canceled.
But it's okay, we win.
It's okay.
But we're out.
oh it's fine we were safe we were safe okay i had to call it
here i need to call it i need to call it here my tie so i
can sleep for the tournament ggs some things qon ggs thanks
for games this is the most you've ever you've ever played
with with me.
He's a two-in-done.
This is actually the longest he's ever played.
Thank you.
Yeah.
All right.
I'm almost done.
Oh, I thought.
Another time.
All right.
Yeah.
Thank you.
It was fun.
Chat liked how you almost went full gaming and then canceled
your ult.
But...
Thank you, everybody, for watching today.
He's saving all for next game.
Yeah, he's saving it for next game.
But thank you, guys.
for watching hey I think we're like even on stream you know
we're not gonna I think we were even on stream you know I
had some we did have some people flaming me but hey that
means I'm in their heads oh shit okay I dropped my water
that's okay because it landed back on the bot landed back on
the bottom so I didn't nothing spilled oh that's cool that
was sick it did flip and Anyway, thank y'all for watching.
If you're new here, I usually stream on the...
Oh, check out Madara.
I think he started...
He's streaming now.
I don't know.
But shout out to Madara.
Feel free to check out his Twitch.
Um...
I think that's his Twitch.
I think.
Unless I...
I don't know.
I just saw him streaming today.
So, check out Madara.
He's a tank for NRG.
Uh, yeah, Madara.
Are you streaming more consistently now?
I know last time you were crying about your internet.
assume your internet's a lot better now, right?
Um, oh yeah, check him out.
He actually plays this game really well.
Not, I'm just here to chill.
I'm mostly just here to just have fun, you know?
I think I'm the happiest rivals player right now in this
Elo.
I think there are happier players, but I think in this Elo,
I might be the happiest player.
just in this elo um but if you're new here my name is adoki
bird i usually stream on youtube i'm gonna stream the
tournament on youtube because i like to keep my bods up for
tournaments um i like to keep on the main channel so i'm
just pure whimsy here um even if i fuck up hey at least i
don't blame any i do blame people if they do deserve it but
but at least like you know i take accountability if I fuck
up you know I I I do take accountability if I if I fuck up
but you know check me on YouTube if you want to know
whenever I stream on Twitch because I do do gorilla streams
on Twitch please feel free to follow me on Twitter because I
usually tweet out whenever I'm on here if you want to
support me via other means.
I do have merch right now, my birthday merch right now that
you can buy.
So yeah, check out my merch.
I have my, I have a gamer subs code, Doki Bird.
I have Fortnite code, Doki Bird.
I have an EA code, Doki Bird.
It's all Doki Bird.
I honestly, if you're like, I wonder if Doki has a code,
just type in Doki Bird.
Most likely I do have a code.
Never keep your eggs and all in one basket.
Yeah, code Doki Bird on everything you think I have.
But yeah, I think Thank you all for the bitties, for the
followers, the subs.
I always love just fucking around in Rivals when I have
time.
And it's been, it was a good stream today.
I didn't think I would stream this long.
But I don't know.
Rivals just does something to me.
I don't know.
I just like chilling.
Like, even when I lose, it's just, I don't know.
When I stream for you guys, when I'm streaming for you guys,
time flies by so fast.
So I'm glad you've been enjoying the stream.
everybody stay hydrated posture checkup and move around to
get that blood flowing you stay up for me head to bed
because you deserve it but yeah check out my dar again he
was the one he was the one brave enough to queue with me on
stream uh so um yeah um the brave the bravest soldier to
play with me on stream so yeah here's i'll just drop his
link again and i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys bye